welcome everybody to the moment you've
been waiting for this is the grand
finals of the i'm not gm speechless
championship grandmaster robert hess
alongside me today as always is grand
mastermon hamilton
amman we have quite a match-up in store
for the people
what do you make of it well hello robert
hello everybody and i hope everyone is
ready for
some prime time action this is the
finals you only get to say that once in
every competition
uh this is roberto molina against gotham
chess aka levy rosman
um this is gonna be a lot of fun robert
i think that what we've seen so far
from levy has been uh just match after
match
uh tons and tons of time scramble issues
but tons and tons of exciting chess
recoveries he's been down in pretty much
every match
and made a comeback to win so uh when it
comes to the finals he's gonna be
up against uh roberto molina a very very
tough opponent who
uh the way i see it he has uh more than
earned
uh his his right to be in the finals
robber he definitely has and he's
thrived in all time controls and let's
remind everybody of what those tie
controls are
because we have three different ones we
start with the 75 minutes
of five plus one blitz that's five
minutes with one second increment we
then
go into the 45 minutes of the three plus
one finally we get 25 minutes of bullet
and that's where levy
has mounted his comebacks but against a
player as strong as roberto molina who
has been solid in all time frames
that's going to be an immense challenge
and also the prize fund has increased
because we just have two people left
there is eighteen hundred dollars on the
line in this matchup the winner gets 900
the rest is split by win percentage
always something to play for no matter
the game number
and let's go over the bracket just to
remind our viewers how we got here
because there are only two players
left standing international master levy
rosman gotham chess taking on
international master roberto molina and
amman
they both earned their spot in this
final roberto he
went through the semis just so clearly
clean match-up it felt like at the end
against lars oscar howard because he
swept the bullet portion against the
very strong norwegian player
yeah and and i think that's a point you
bring up that we should focus on for
the match upcoming against levy um
because
there's going to be some fireworks
whenever one of the players has made
most if not all of his comebacks in the
bullet portion and meanwhile you're
dealing with
a guy on the other side of the table who
just swept one of the best bullet
players in the competition
so this is a doubtlessly a heavyweight
match up no matter what but
especially make sure to focus on that
bullet section when we get there guys
because
we have two 2 800 class bullet players
going head to head
and uh robert what i'm what i'm saying
is you know hey if you're levy rosman
i think you got to keep this a lot
closer in the blitz portion
because roberto is not going to be
giving up as much ground for those
comebacks and bullets
that's absolutely correct that deficit
that levy faced against greg shahadi
especially losing the last few
three-minute games that won't do against
roberto molina because roberto is so
quick
and he's so solid he just doesn't make
the blunders we've seen some other
people make throughout this event of
course he is
beatable he's lost many games in this
contest these are long matches but
roberto has proven his might
time after time and so levy will have
his handful
with the brazilian star so aman we're
just about
ready to see the action take place i'm
excited for it we're going to get a
whole lot of karakan today
yeah you you hinted at that in the last
match if you can see the players on cams
there this is going to be
cairo khan centric uh basically who
cracks first
i wonder um because it's an interesting
thing when
when both players play an opening all of
a sudden you know they're probably doing
a lot of their work from the other side
in order to try to get a good position
against it in order to try to beat it so
for once robert both these guys are
gonna have to open up those uh
those theoretical books and try to find
a good line to play against an opening
they both like
i find it super awkward to play against
my favorite openings because i'm like
wait that looks good can i
switch colors right here but we see d4
by roberto so no carrot con
for levy at least not in this first game
and we see a queen's gambit we're off to
a
qga i'm a bit surprised by that decision
but
perhaps i shouldn't be yeah the qga
just characterized uh as robert
mentioned there accept it accepting the
gambit
um d takes c4 so a temporary extra pawn
for black and
i say temporary robert because that's
already been evened out
it has and levy moving very quickly out
of the gates here that's a good sign for
his fans and for him
because he has shown some questionable
time management
in the five-minute portion but right now
he actually has a slight lead it's still
early stages
i tend to like white's position for now
but you can see black
quickly getting a c5 move castle king's
side and try to take over some squares
on the queen side and that's how
black's position can get better but look
at this knight d2 that knight can go to
b3
and c5 becomes increasingly difficult to
play
yeah and because of the styles here um i
think that
roberto's style being so solid is one
that you really have to be careful as
levy not to get down on time against
it's one of the worst things robert to
be first of all down on time in general
but
down on time when your opponent is just
playing quick solid moves
is it's a really really tough thing to
face and you know we could see him
getting uh flagged in a lot of like
relatively equal positions where the
only difference is the clock so one
thing
to be careful of going forward as the
move a6 has been played
robert he didn't want that pawn to show
up on a6 for white
no he certainly did not but we saw that
a6 pawn dropped by
lars in the previous matchup against
roberto so look at the queen and bishop
lined up against the a6 pawn well
defended for the time being
but if the knight moves and that rook
follows suit that a6 pawn could drop
that's a permanent target
and look at white expanding in the
center i already really like roberto's
position however
levy has shown some very good
understanding of positions that may seem
a bit you know worse with less space
and things of that nature but he's been
able to hold his own and keracons and
here in this queen's game accept it yeah
and speaking of less space
e5 make sure to uh drive that point home
e5 knight d5 so a nice square in the
center for levy but whenever you see
this in balance
e5 knight d5 you always got to pay
attention to the king side all of a
sudden a bishop on d3
queen on e4 gonna launch a really quick
attack against the king side because
there's no knight that can ever appear
on f6 to play defense again
you might see something like rook d1
intermediate
take that pawn back whenever he wants
that's a great move rook to d and i like
that better but he takes with the f3
knight and you may be wondering why is
he moving his knight away from the king
side but that opens up the queen
potentially to go to g4 or to h5
depending on what happens in the next
few moves
and so white can go forward with an
attack and remember that a6 pawn amman
if knight c6 perhaps i can just trade on
c6 and steal
that a6 pawn so black has to be careful
not to drop that pawn on the a file
well this is roberto molina we're
talking about and you just said the word
trade so
knight c6 not something that i think
levy's going to be going for
early on uh wow and there he goes and
there's the trade
i mean robert we're just calling these
these uh these moves play by play this
is this
is too easy at the moment why why is
that bond not takeable uh i think you
could just capture that and i think you
probably
should because that knight on b3 defends
the a5 pawn sometimes you give up a pawn
and then win the pawn that's behind the
one you sacrifice but then a5 pawn
safe and sound there i would be just you
know grabbing that pawn
pretty quickly enjoying it and then
asking levi to prove that he has enough
compensation for it
i'm just glad that you're going to enjoy
the pond as well because i just hate
these pawn grabbers these days robert
that take pawns that don't enjoy them
that's that's uh part of the part of the
the gluttony you know
bishop takes a6 he's really thinking
here the uh what we have seen
as counter play towards taking one of
some of these free pawns especially in
the
uh match against lars was immediate
counter play on the king side
so something like bishop g5 and maybe
trying to trade and get the queen out to
g5 there's been a lot of counterplay on
the
g2 square um so i think roberto is is
making some considerations right now and
he doesn't
end up going for it is that ptsd from
his last match and some of the
counterplay he experienced
i i think he just is a very practical
player he says i could take on a6 that
may give levy some tactical
opportunities that you were just
discussing
so let me play positionally that pawn a6
is not going anywhere and if black's
best move is bishop c6
back to b7 that rook and eight still
can't leave the square and so
i can bring my brooks in the center and
black has a harder time doing so
right that's a good point just the
patience and saying that that pawn on a6
is always going to be there and
if i'm not going to win it well i'm
going to tie down two of your pieces
the defense of that pawn for the rest of
the game so he does go back and defend
it though
i'm just wondering is roberto going to
regret that decision not grabbing the
pawn when he could
i'm just trying to figure out what
black's exact plan is probably queen
d7 because the a8 rook can't move but
that rook on f8 would love to join the
party so maybe that rook and f8 lands on
d8 or c8 depending on how
white plays so queen e7 is a good start
and i'm not really seeing how roberto
can take advantage of the fact that his
rook is the first one in the game so
he's kind of
one move ahead if we think about in
terms of development and yet there's no
immediate way that i see to take
advantage of it he's going for it queen
g4
yeah he's trying to say look uh bishop
h6 works really
well with queen g4 there's no bishop f6
no knight f6
that pawn on e5 doing work bishop h6
right now is a huge threat
because if you play g6 well don't forget
that rook on f8 is behind and that's why
we see the move
king h8 played it's not a move that levy
wants to play
bishop h6 is such a big threat and uh
the king side just belongs to white here
that pawn on e5
compared to the counter player on e6
just gained so much space controls so
many squares here
if the rook could move like a knight for
a quick second and hop onto the third
rank and get a rook lift
then black could be in big trouble if
that rook could just take the elevator
up to d3
scoot on over to the king side that
would be excellent but that takes so
much time at the moment you have to go
bishop e1
trying to find like some tactics to make
it work but it feels slow so he goes
direct he's saying
hey i don't need my rook out there i'm
just going to push my pawn up the board
and maybe i'll play bishop to g5 which
trades off one of black's defenders over
there and then play rook to d3 try to
get the c5 square for my knight
a lot of different possibilities at this
point and
uh speaking of different possibilities
levy is probably noticing
that wait a minute that queen on g4
while you're making some threats and
while my king has had to sidestep to h8
keep in mind it's no longer on e2 so
that a6 pawn that we've been talking
about for the entire opening phase of
the game
no longer attacked and that's why levy
takes the opportunity to say look rook a
to c8
now i can get that rook out the guy who
was previously tied to the the
defense of the apon and uh whether
there's going to be a queen g3 played
whether there's going to be some
sacrifices on c4 or not
i'm not sure what to i mean queen a4
even comes to mind as
an idea here and levy just playing the
solid chess queen e8 but sometimes solid
is not the way to go and it's seen based
on the eval bar something was missed i'm
now looking at the position maybe some
kind of knight c3 move just cutting off
the rook on c1 from the bishop on c4 but
i was helped out by the evo where
i'm not certain about that but queen
eight feels like a very normal move it's
helping to get your queen off of the
line of the rook on d1
your queen's closer to the king side to
help in the defense if white brings more
forces
i don't mind that move one bit not at
all queen e8 makes a lot of sense um
we've been mentioning moves to follow up
for roberto h5 and bishop g5 both look
consistent
h5 has the idea of playing h6 if you
play g6
then you can follow up with something
like bishop to g5 and you start to take
control of some of those dark squares
around the king where it was very very
dangerous for levi so i think
h5 by white would be met with something
like h6 by black
although is knight c3 now an even bigger
threat because the queen moved off the
d-file
and the rook would like to take that
bishop on c4 so knight c3 is in the air
yeah and you always wonder with tactics
like that especially when they may have
been available last turn
it's like is your opponent going to
notice them if you keep
leaving that idea there maybe roberto is
saying well my opponent didn't see it
last turn
i i i guess he's not going to notice at
this turn but it's always annoying when
you notice a tactic and you're not sure
whether your opponent does
but of course you always have to react
and play the best move
yeah you don't want to have wishful
thinking he does play h5 you recommend
it but look at the clock situation we
don't say this very often
but levy has about double the time that
his opponent does so
all of a sudden it's levy with the lead
on the clock and with a position that
looks very stable
but h6 for black or h6 for white that's
the big question right now
and levy should spend some time trying
to figure that out yeah you mentioned
knight c3 but even going for that move
when h6 is available
um h6 is always going to be punched in
at the end of a lot of variations
so um i i like the move h6
for black however i i understand
sometimes even after h6
you can play things like i know it looks
crazy robert but g takes h6
followed by something like queen g8 and
all of a sudden white might actually
regret
opening the king up funny as that may
sound yeah that bishop on
b7 is so strong over there and one thing
if black plays h6 i'm looking for like a
bishop d3 bishop b1
queen d3 let's get a battery and go
checkmate you on h7
and it seems very far away but that is
one of white's plans in a position like
this but here we go roberto pushes
through to h6
we're getting a bullet scramble at this
point now levy
is down 10 make it 15 seconds in a
second here
and i'm starting to like roberto's
position based on the ease of play
yeah and i know the eval bar is going up
but somehow i don't mind this queen g8
idea i feel like the better way to
execute it was
to take and then get the queen over so
it'd sort of be
almost with tempo on the queen but i do
like
the g file opening up for black and we
start to see the eval bar agree with
that
yeah i put my bishop back on f1
something that we talked about from the
early stages we kind of forgot about it
we tabled it
that a6 pawn still a weakness so the
bishop on b7 stuck in place defending
that the bishop
goes back to e2 it could have also gone
back to f1 but i like this move
now that a6 pawn even without the rooks
on the board will still be a problem for
black
will and the a5 pawn conversely it's
really hard to attack the knight on b3
is defending it very solidly
and bishop d8 is such a strange way to
to go about attacking that thing bishop
d3 covers
c2 so even though levy has the open file
here robert you can't use any of those
squares
i really like that with bishop g5 though
because now you help your pawn structure
bring it
close to the center no longer isolate
h-bond and you can get some of the
squares in the c-file but not yet
c1 c2 c3 c4 c5 all under white's control
funnily enough but 97 opening that
bishop up and
well this is just a time scramble and i
don't like that move i feel like you
could even just go for the trade
rook c2 is a big threat here and that e
pawn
i think it's gonna start to feel over
extended so i think this is uh levy's
game
yeah he's doing really well to get here
and right now he plays rook c4 he wants
to go king f5 you can bring that king in
there could be a g4 check but that gives
black the f4 square
so he brings his knight back to c7 that
may have been
that's a step in the wrong direction i
was gonna say i thought he was maybe
just gonna put it right back on d5 which
is okay like
and sometimes in these positions don't
be afraid to shuffle pieces
it's all about the time it's plus one
second increment and knight f4
is a fantastic outpost it isn't oh okay
he barely got that move on
0.1 seconds left and now he loses on
time do you think roberto just forgot
about the clock he was moving
way too deliberately with no time
remaining
and it's funny because when you said
that he barely got that move off
i saw him almost like bring his hand up
as if he thought he was gonna flag
and then his hand was like off the mouse
so he really did flag or something
i wasn't sure what happened there but
not a good start for roberto molina
because
that time pressure is is going to be
present for the entire match robert that
plus one second
players have to get used to the fact
that's that's not
fairly enough time to process your
opponent's move let alone make your own
that's very true and credit to levy for
playing great defense at first and then
just having purpose to all of his moves
he was able to season advantage in the
end game and roberto couldn't keep up
on the clock and the position was
starting to favor black as well so right
now
we have a carrot con this is the
gretchen hottie line the two nights
variation that levy had a few words
about he's like why are you playing this
maybe he said not so bad after all i
like what i faced
and here we see that with the white
pieces levy has the bishop pair
he has the d-pawn black has an e-pawn so
not a symmetrical pawn structure
and white has a bit more space but black
is so solid the b7 c6
and f7 e6 pawn chains there they blunt
the bishop on e2
can't find that great of a diago at
least not for the near future
yeah a little uh nod there to greg
jihadis like man why are you playing
this boring line well
actually i don't mind that position let
me have a go at that um
a4 played by levy early on you may be
wondering what that move is
all about just trying to gain a little
bit of space there a4 up to a5
sort of reminiscent of the space that
was gained by uh white in the previous
position
with that a pawn so queen over to b3 not
sure the queen is
necessarily the best on b3 but you can
see the setup he's going for
he wants to control the d5 square and he
wants to at
all costs keep the bishop pair on the
board so
you know if bishop g5 happens knight d5
you won't see him i think trading those
bishops he's trying to keep them on the
board
that's right and well if you can't beat
them you join them and
levy did have some struggles against
greg's openings
in the caricom very interesting match
neither side really pulled ahead and it
was the bullet as we mentioned
that gave levy the wind but that wasn't
no it wasn't any longer in the kerala
con
in the same way so let's see here we
have the knight on d5
it's established black can't push those
pawns though if you push c5
then your b7 pawn feels very loose if
you push e5
well white's already ready for that
because the rook on e1 the pawn on d4
it seems like you're leaving some things
quite vulnerable so right now
levy needs to find a move and what is
that move because your position looks
kind of perfect i don't know how to
proceed
yeah i always like playing g3 and i'm a
big fan of starting to get the pawns on
dark squares g3
and h4 and then even maybe considering
h5 in the future but g3 is also a great
move to just control the f4 square
it's a square that black can use for a
number of his pieces and we do see the
move g3
getting the king up to g2 h4 sliding the
rook to h1
going for h5 it's almost as you said
robert the position is so perfect for
the rest of the pieces
well all the moves that i'm suggesting
have nothing to do with them these are
just slow moves to improve
the king side position and maybe hint at
a potential h file attack
i like it incremental progress may be
the way to go and if all of your
major pieces are on their best squares
you need to make a pawn breakthrough and
there are seven pawns per side not open
files to work with right
semi-open d-file for black semi-open
e-file for white but you're staring into
a protected pawn there and look at
roberto he says i'm done
sitting and waiting i'm pushing my pawn
to b5 which stops you from playing c4
i can also open the b file at a moment's
notice and that pawn on b2
can start feeling like it's in danger so
i like the decisions by roberto because
he couldn't just sit and wait forever
and there's going to be a move bishop c1
which i think is
kind of instrumental um okay he goes wow
he goes c4
totally different direction usually
black is pretty happy to see this but i
was going to hint at bishop c1
guarding the b-pawn in case the the
b-file got open we saw that utilized by
greg
very effectively in in the match against
levy but instead
totally different approach and one that
i'm not a really big fan of robert
because that pawn on d4
it's going to require support for the
rest of the game yeah i'm trying to look
at levy for any reaction so far it just
looks like roberto
trying to regain his composure and levy
not
really showing much on his face at least
but i did not like that decision either
that pawn on d4 isolated under attack
multiple times
and now look at your bishop on c3 that
bishop is a big pawn
defending d4 defending b2 and black can
even consider
c5 here trying to rip open the position
put pressure on d4 the rook would love
to recapture on c5 hit your
queen hit your bishop behind it i think
that roberto now has
all of the initiative and white needs to
be very careful not to be in
huge trouble the next few moves and c5
is a strong move we'll see if he takes
the time here i mean it's three and a
half minutes on the clock
for roberto he's got lots of time c5 is
a move he can calculate out
but it's not the solid approach you know
it that pawn often does stay
on c6 the counterpart on e6 supporting
d5
um it's yeah it's just a totally
different style to play the move c5
then i would guess uh robert wants to
handle the position a little bit
differently here
well roberto did talk about this in the
post-match interview he says i don't
want the tactics i want the positional
chest i want to trade
and so c5 is welcoming tactics that are
a bit unclear
so he plays h5 just stops some action on
the king side
maybe he'll play a move like bishop g7
just to make sure his bishop is safe and
protected by the king
i could see him taking that sort of
approach but i do believe that c5
is a good move here and it may be time
to pounce agreed
c5 is is screaming right now we might
see those other moves
queen b6 king g7 but i think any other
move
it just gives levy time to sort of
recuperate here and get his pieces on
better squares now that the uh structure
on the queen side and in center has
changed a little bit earlier it was it
was actually levy
who i think had all the time to play
with his pieces were all in great
squares and we do see that
i mean b6 just these slow moves are not
what
this particular position needs you know
what i'm thinking that he did not want
to see a queen sacrifice of c5 we can
show that in the analysis
board really quickly that if instead of
queen b6 he played c5
perhaps there was pawn takes c5 rook
takes c5 and then queen takes c5
because after the queen is captured the
bishop on f6 hangs and that's actually a
scary looking position i know that black
based on the eval bar on screen here is
better but i wouldn't be
feeling comfortable with my king on g8
and so many dark squares vulnerable
that's a great point um i'd be really
interested to know
if roberto calculated something the
likes of that but
that would be the exactly the type of
line that would scare roberto off
because it's unclear you don't know
what's the what the
real evaluation of that position is
instead he's got a solid
solid game knight on d5 there's there's
no way that we could look at his
position and
you know have any concerns about
roberto's position
he's much more likely to take on c3 and
then play c5 or well he played knight b4
here just
keeping that d4 pawn in place he is just
trying to play
sound chess and that often is a good
thing and it works very well for him
he's an extremely strong player
but i do think that it prevents him from
getting more out of certain positions
and this one is no exception to that so
what white has
struggling to defend his d4 pawn i'm not
even sure how you
can defend it queen f4 played and that
looks good i'm getting out of
the pin on the d file so no more e5
ideas or c5
and i think it's a reasonable situation
for levy at this point
i think so as well he might return
actually with the knight to d5
um hitting the queen and you know just
trying to come up with a
another decision there i mean there is a
repetition on the port 95 queen d2
always got to be on the lookout for
those um but i
i think if you're roberto here you play
this on there if you get a carrot con
position
with an isolated pawn on d4 i mean just
pay attention that this levy is doing
nothing but playing defense right now
this is a dream karo khan for black and
he's up on time so
i think if you if you have a way to play
on you take it
so he does play knight to d5 hoping for
bishop takes d5 please take me there my
rook can take back on d5 and
i'm just largely in charge there in the
center so
i think that after 95 queen d2 will be
played and maybe roberto will take on c3
he doesn't have to he could play knight
b4 and go for the repetition
and amman i'm thinking about this from a
match perspective yes he is down one
point he lost the first game but that
was on time in a
nearly level position i don't think he
should be upset if he makes a drawn
remains down on the scoreboard
so he could repeat but look at levy
playing queen e4 i'm not sure
if that's playing for moore or there's
something he didn't like about queen d2
yeah there is something to be said about
just not repeating because
maybe your opponent wants you to repeat
so they can change their move to a
better one
instead you take it upon yourself repeat
and well
talk about repetition i mean g4 robert
he's saying look
i don't want any type of draw with the
move g4 highly committal
i expected to move rook h8 probably
going to be followed up with something
like rook
h1 but this changes the scope of
everything as now
levy's pawn structure robert is terrible
he has to win tactically
he must and we heard roberto talk about
this i don't want to get into tactics
but if they happen
i can do it and that's what happened in
the game against lars last
match where his king was on e7 or
something in the opening and he won that
game when the
action really started heating up so
right now the f4 square
was what black was looking for bishop d2
says no not for you
and i would probably try to move my king
away to f8 and start running because i
don't want
h5 to happen and my king to be sitting
right in the crossfire
yeah it's actually um pretty safe for
the king on e7 surprisingly
and opening up that g file not exactly
what levy wants to do after king f8
because the rook might slide to g8 with
a pin and bishop d2 play because
you want to get out of the potential
exchange you also want to take control
over the f4 square very important to
stop knight f4 that's the main reason he
couldn't punch in h5 right away
and a big problem for white is the clock
but also the d4 pawn that remains a
weakness
so if the knight moves away from d5 at
some point that d4 pawn could fall but
look at him bishop e7 he wants knight f6
and levy says have fun with knight f6
because i'm still going for you
and yet now he's thinking 10 seconds
counting down you got to move
and now there's no more attack now yeah
the attack just ends here which is
always tough and the queens getting
traded should be a good thing for black
especially with that pawn on h6
in an end game that pun's just gonna get
picked off yeah that's
a great king on h7 blocking the pawn no
attack there's no knight to jump to g5
for example so you cannot boot the king
from his blockading square and now d4 is
a potential target and rook
a8 just to defend a5 and i guess defend
c6 and play b6 look at that maneuver
getting a rook to the b
file yeah he needs to get there at some
point and
uh levy if he can play rook c1 and say
look take
h pawn i'll take your c pawn he'd love
to make that trade because that h-pawn
is pretty much a goner anyways
and so he gets knight before and now he
should play c5 at long last he does it
because the rook on a6 is the heroic
piece defending the e6 pawn
it's true but rook c1 we're seeing some
activation with four seconds here by
levy
pawn is going to get to e5 it looks like
and support that bishop
lock that bishop on g3 out of the game
permanently the rook on a6 is still
defending things robert
it is a great piece and bishop g4 played
rookie seven that bishop on g3
very poor piece and well i like the move
f4 though we're talking about how bad
that bishop is now let's try to open
things up and whoa
getting tactical it should be coming to
g6 that king could get mated but it has
the g7 square for now
yeah oh this is i mean the rook the
problem is the rook on e2 just
now he sees it oh wait why do you take
the point to the bishop
f5 e3 he's still got a lot of pawns here
he does but he could have taken
a bishop and he took a pawn there that
was a f4
who's better i have no idea look at
these rooks they're not coordinated very
well
oh my gosh in two seconds and now that
pun would be take
f3 or take the b2 pawn i'm not sure
which is better f3
f3 what is happening here f2 is that the
rook is hanging but rook takes b1
but then bishop d4 i mean it's pawns i
don't know
[Laughter]
oh my god black is winning it's gonna be
we to go
e2 and bishop c3 oh here it comes okay
so what now
before bishop c3 oh that's so nice and
then e2 check
yeah what a game he wins he's down a
rock
oh gosh and levy kind of laughs it off
but uncomfortably so and roberto's just
like what did i go through i went
through eight games
in one oh my goodness
roberto comes away with the victory
from one of the most insane imbalances
i've seen for an extended period of time
sometimes you'll see these imbalances
and you know oh they'll just sack for
those pawns but
we had a rook versus three pawns robert
for like 20 moves
and it all started roberto actually hung
his rook on d6 for free
and then he was able elite to get some
first a bishop and then a bunch of pawns
for it so three pawns for a rook
wow that was a crazy game and both sides
need to calm down because it's only two
games into the match
it's 1-1 still early stages and
levy going for a dutch type of setup
aimed at the e4 square knight f5 pawn
bishop on b7 saying no e4 for you
and for roberto here well he's gonna
have to figure out an exact plan to
press forward because you don't just
want to sit on the bus you want to open
things up at some point
yeah knight e4 has been played and i
mean i'll just show one of the
possibilities knight takes e4 bishop
takes e4 and reason i mention this is
because the bishop on e4
we've talked about a position like this
in some of the london variations
in previous matches but you want to have
this pin on the bishop so if white ever
has ideas
to move the knight you always get that
trait which is nice for black
get rid of that strong bishop on g2 and
otherwise you see how you're kind of
holding the bishop on g2 hostage here
and always keeping that trade uh in
reserve and we're seeing something
similar to that in the game
and it just happened to be that black
took on c3 and well
white has lined the queen and bishop up
on the long diagonal that bishop on e4
sits
comfortably in place sometimes white
goes for something like bishop h3 or
rook move and bishop f1 so you can avoid
the
trade of the light square bishops and he
does move his rook so maybe bishop
reform could be next
but that bishop on e4 still remains
extremely powerful
yeah let's not forget about this knight
on a6 it kind of looks like a weird move
maybe
um it was played earlier but keep in
mind you know if d5 happens which
makes a lot of sense to open up this
bishop the knight is always ready to
jump in knight c5 and then potentially
jump in
to e4 but forget about that knight on a6
for a second what about f4 from levy
he's
trying to punch in some uh threats on
the king side without
many pieces over there at all yeah it
looks quite committal
although at this point you don't really
want to trade on c3 because
you're the one trying to open up an
attack and if you trade on c3 maybe it's
your king on g8 that will be in more
trouble than anything so bishop h6
is a move here and you can say wait
maybe the next move i'll play g5
g4 open up that f file get after your f2
pawn
but instead he just goes knight c5 which
that seems
kind of counter-intuitive considering
what he's just done with f4 and f6 g3
definitely um i'm you know considering
immediately ideas like b4 and why would
i
would i be scared of b4 knight a4 so i'm
looking at like maybe pawn d6
and trade the bishops and try to go for
an end game that
is something that i'm sure roberto is
considering if we think of him
stylistically
he knows that the bishops and queens all
disappear from the board
with one move bishop takes uh g7 and
uh what can i say robert just i'm in
tune with my queen trading
friend over here you did a perfect job
there and it's a trade happening take on
g7
queens come off rook takes d6 and guess
what it's black with that problem on d7
these rook on c1 slides directly over to
d1 that knight can hop into e5 at any
moment
b4 can be played to kick the knight out
of c5 this looks
extremely promising for roberto and most
importantly it's his style
and not levies yeah one thing that i'm
just noticing um i'll show it on the
board is like
uh knight to e5 as a potential move
might run into something like takes on
g2 followed by rook takes f2
with um cute little tactic there knight
e4 check and then taking on d6 now
what's the evaluation of that i don't
know might even still be good for
roberto but
um doubtlessly something that he has to
consider as actually he's just gonna go
grab a pawn there
well he went a5 to stop b4 and then rook
takes b6 happened and it's like
well that the cure was worse than the
disease because i just dropped my pawn
on b6 for free and my d7
pawn is still backwards it's gonna be
weak and rook b5 can be played knight e5
all the same stuff that
was happening earlier and now white has
an extra pawn to boot so this is
a very bad situation for levy roberto
he's salivating it's an end game
he's up a pawn he doesn't even need to
trade but he can so this is looking good
for white in game three here
looking fantastic uh matches his style
and he's just such a technician
when it comes to positions like this
knight d4 i mean what's the material
here i think it's only one pawn
but it feels like a little bit more than
that don't forget it's also a time
advantage
as well as a position that roberto is
very happy to take his time with and
make sure he converts properly this is a
his chance to not only bounce back from
an insane tactical game
but take the lead in the match from a
technical position
though we have said that sometimes he
gets a little bit too solid
and now levy plays a4 he's only up one
pawn
so if we get into a rook end game the
knights get traded off it could be
too little of an advantage to win the
game the conversion will be difficult i
like rook b1 keeping more pieces on the
board
and i will say that it may not seem
relevant or even noticeable
but the fact that black has an outside
pass pawn on the king side
could be very annoying that if you play
h5 g5 and h4 at the right moment
you can distract white's forces over to
the h file
and then block and try to play on the
rest of the board and try to salvage the
game
and we see my opinion a really really
strong move there
rook to b4 it fixes the pawn on b3
and levi was hinting that he was about
to play e5
kicking the knight away taking on b3 uh
roberto said nope
f4 you're not going to have that one
levi said well actually i'm going to
have one of them
d5 and he's trying to take advantage of
the pin that that rook on b4 has against
the knight
anyways rook c1 but i think the problem
with this is knight takes b3 you cannot
take on e6
with even those check because after king
f6 now your rook on c1
and your knight and e6 are under attack
at the same time so the tactics
don't seem to work out unless i'm
missing something there
but i think knight takes e6 king f6 will
do
oh there's nice c7 there what a weird
position now i'm just like
confused and he takes on b3 and what
looks like a
even by material end game and i think
you still
have something to play for after rook c7
here um
definitely not completely over levi's
done a great job to reach this position
down a clean pawn and when i say clean i
mean like he played a5 and a pawn was
just removed from the board in his
position
to be here i mean full credit to levy
rosman for
making this uh a position to look
forward to but king h6 this is exactly
why i was saying
you want to play this position on i
mentioned at the start one thing we're
gonna see robert is equal positions
where levy's down on time
and you might think oh you know that's
just flagging well the
the clock is uh part of things and you
might get checkmated in a couple moves
g4
g5 for white uh there's g4 step one
black has to play g5
otherwise white does so and checkmate's
rook takes h7
so g5 for black then maybe white plays
f5
and it's close to stalemate so if this
d-pawn goes off the board you can just
give away your rook and that would be a
stalemate
but for now black is in some danger some
very serious trouble
and perhaps it's holdable it just
doesn't look very fun
no it doesn't at all um rook d6 here
king back pawn takes pawn is a way to
win a pawn robert but
i don't think roberto is even
considering something like that because
it doubles his pawns
um he's probably more interested in
either something
slower like e3 or just f5 there is not
going to be a stalemate there's
two mobile pieces and pawns on the board
so
it would take a miracle to get rid of
all of that at once and remember
he always has rook d6 check to get rid
of a stalemate
in case you know levy ever tries to just
get rid of all his pieces at once
it's a good call and he's thinking which
leads me to believe that he might
actually try to win this pawn with a
rook d6 check
and after king g7 then take on g5 but
that doesn't feel like it gives you
any winning chances i don't like the
presence of the double pawns
and he plays e3 that's a tricky move
inviting g takes f4 hey now we're
instead of losing upon blocking trade
pawns but after e takes f4
the threat of g5 check is still alive
now there is a pass pawn in the making
regardless and i think that's a good
decision considering levy's clock
i i think i would still say that g takes
f4
is the move to play um and after pawn
takes just go rook d3 check
as long as the king is not you know
close to those two pawns
i think that levy can can manage the
defense with just his king in front of
them
yeah he should be able to hold this he
has 42 seconds so he's down quite a bit
on the clock but plenty of time
remaining
to salvage this and well he says rook d1
will keep the status quo if king the e2
kicking the black rook from the d5 pawn
then the rook goes over to g1 and
attacks the g4 pawn so a trade
will benefit black's chances of holding
so that would be a situation that
levy would be completely comfortable
with yeah and
you know the only other real try is
something like f5 and keep in mind
you may consider at some point e4 um
just because you can see that it's
pinned but at the moment with the king
on f3 pawn takes pawn is going to be a
check so it'd be a
kind of a disaster move there and we see
king e2 i think rook g1
is going to be punched in and there it
is only move i think and the king back
to f3 just to defend then we'll see rook
back to d1 and
i don't think we will see a draw by
repetition at this point but that's what
levy is aiming for
just annoy the g4 pawn the king has to
go back to defend
then go right back to d1 to defend your
weak pawn on d5
i mean this is exactly what you want if
you're roberto remember
levy had like a minute and change and
roberto had three minutes well that's
changed to a minute and 30 seconds
i i know that you know technically levy
might have gained time on the clock but
okay well with that move i think we are
pretty much going for a i was gonna say
just going for a draw but
seems like both guys are trying to get
fancy here yeah king g6
probably not incredibly necessary but
the point was if rook takes h7 there
could have been a rook g7 check with a
trade or a win of the rook if you're not
careful so he goes kg6 he just wants to
take all the pawns in a row rook takes
g4
rook takes g5 next and after king of
three rook f1 check the king will have
to
go away from these g pawns at some point
and thus black is holding on
yep and i think we've reached total
equality and in fact
so much equality that they've just
agreed to a draw right there no need to
play it out so
uh i gotta give a lot of credit to levy
there for
handling that position that that was
quite something robert he was a clear
pawn down
against someone who you know we might
both uh
both agree is well suited to
take home that full point and he wasn't
able to against levy's defense
have to give praise to levy's defense
but i think i need to be critical
about roberto's play because he had such
a
dominating position and then he went for
trades and it's not like he lost all of
his advantage no of course not he still
was better
but i think he does that where he just
gets in this mindset of let me play
solidly so i don't have to get any
tactics to worry about let me just trade
stay up a pawn
and that can backfire in these
situations when there are not too many
pieces remaining so i do believe
that roberto is playing excellent chess
i just think that there are times where
he is
too risk-averse yeah completely agree
and
you know that's that's our tough job up
here uh robert we we get to
be critical like that because we we can
see the the type of play that's required
in every position but that's the thing
about chess
everyone has styles so while his style
uh may have been the reason that he
didn't get the full point there
it's also gonna be the reason why he's
getting full points elsewhere so
um that's just how styles uh styles
cause different people to calculate and
be comfortable with different lines but
um we're into the next game it's one and
a half one and a half so
this could be a very uh a pivotal match
here is we're waiting for someone to
take the lead again and roberto
has never had the lead in the match so
far he's playing his his
uh you know his coveted power con robert
is he gonna be able to get a win with
the black pieces here
and i'm looking at the pawn structure we
have the bathtub on the king side right
from e5
f4g for h5 and that's a lot of space
gained
for white but look at black darting the
king over to the other side of the board
saying well
what attack are you going to have when
my king's over there and often you
attack
not just to checkmate but to gain space
open files and then take advantage
here it's not so easy to accomplish that
and if white isn't careful
black will break in the center with a
timely move like f6
i would probably put my king on b8 even
if it's not required here
i made this reference last night but
building good habits when you castle
queenside you often want to tuck your
king
closer to the corner right yes you do
it's it's almost an automatic move just
because that pawn on a7
isn't quite defended and the c file
often opens up
so king b8 makes a lot of sense
especially here it would allow the
knight to also go to c8 potentially
and a6 played an ultra solid move he's
looking
at stuff like c5 but he wanted to play
a6 first
so there's definitely no knight b5 which
would have been catastrophic to allow
certainly the case and now knight f3 so
levi has developed all of his minor
pieces
roberto's bishop on f8 still stuck back
there f6
is a consideration c5 for sure i still
would think about king to b8 i want to
get my king out of there
even if there's no big deal with playing
c5 and the king's
safe king bait just looks like a good
move and it also opens up
rook c8 if you want to bring more pieces
in the c file
as the position starts to open well um
queen takes a5 is at least the first
thing that's coming to my mind
that is a free pawn and it's with a
check now i think that
you think you you would think twice
about this robert because you know
you're taking upon
on the queen side it's where your king
is it's gonna be an open line against
you however
it's kind of hard to refuse upon like
that with chat
it is but for roberto he wants no part
of that because it opens up a file which
means that there could be sacrifices
on the a6 square in front of his king so
i would not be in the business of taking
that after
queen takes a5 that could even be b4 as
the response take another pawn with
check why don't you
i'm just trying to open lines for my
rooks and of course roberto says
yeah i'm good thanks for the offer but i
have enough pawns
don't need yours so he plays knight c8
opens up the bishop
for c5 he can also play bishop h7 to e4
at some moment
which doesn't seem like a big deal but
it can be a bit annoying for white to
deal with that
just because you never know is what
black in the take on
f3 is you're just trying to put a piece
in the center and then have you figure
out what to do
i'm not quite certain how white
progresses in this position either
i think that after knight c8 roberts is
also hinting at the move c5 again
where he's got the knight in bishop
supporting it one thing that i'm looking
at is
c3 and b4 if levy gets the move b4
in it's got complete domination on the
queen side i would be thinking as black
that
c5 here might be my last chance to play
a move like that
um as white i think there's uh something
to be said for just b4
queen d2 and long castling putting your
king
on the queen side where it's out of
danger instead he goes rook h3
getting out of that pin from the bishop
on e4 but i'm waiting for b4 here i
think that could be pivotal
and that's why roberto played g6 because
of your idea of b4 it's white just
claiming all the space in the queen side
so let me fight for some on the king
side
and i like the move g6 knight to d2
played and roberto just takes on h5 so
quickly that mentally pre-moved and if
knight takes e4 you can probably throw
an
h takes g4 hitting the rook on h3 the
intermezzo
is actually quite a fascinating one yeah
and we're going to get a position where
there might be a pawn on e4 that white
is interested in capturing
but it could be met with something like
f5 guarding the pawn and
if you take knight takes f6 suddenly
position gets a little bit open
and there's a king sitting on e1 it's
not
not too sure where that king feels safe
is it going to be the king side well
definitely not
and the queen side well once you maybe
castle queenside
don't forget that pawn on a5 is still
hanging wow
and this position is rich and it's
almost funny
that with the position opening up you'd
expect the bishops to be happy but the
king is on e1 so opening up the position
probably not too favorable for white
just yet and f5 played your movement
if on poisson e takes f6 and the knight
captures and he goes back bishop e2 but
now black
is up a pawn granted it's this h6 pawn
which can't move and is isolated
so if i'm roberto i'd probably play
knight e7 try to get my knight to d5
just advance in the position because the
bishop on f8 may not
i forgot about that pawn and he takes it
i completely forgot about that pawn's
existence
i think the knight is gonna end up on c5
here i mean it makes a lot of sense
knight c5
something like takes b takes opening up
another file
and then with this solid pawn mass in
the middle
we might just see that the rook slowly
relocates to the queen side and just a
full on attack and
roberto is looking at e6 pawn that one's
hanging now i think
well you don't really have a choice you
don't like he plays rookie eight but i
say i don't think you want to play that
move
he's latching on to that e6 pawn as it
also defends the f5 pawn
but i would have just brought my knight
out like knight to b6 knight to d5
try to get quick play there is a white
king still in the center it may not seem
easy to attack
but if my knight ventures up to the d5
square then eventually i got a rook g8
type of move
i could see white's king getting in some
trouble
absolutely and this is all gonna come
down to i think that d5 square after
knight to c5
there are a lot of sacrifices heating up
i think you've got to get rid of that
knight
because a6 is hanging to you know
multiple pieces here
and don't forget that e pawn is hanging
as well knight takes e6
it's actually the bigger threat and he
takes the knight i wasn't quite sure how
he would take because the bishop on the
fate now stinks
it does protect the h6 pawn and i'm
looking with
a6 is hanging so that is for stars he
plays king e8
he fortunately has knight a7 next
because bishop takes a6
would lead to a checkmate if not for the
knight being able to block on a7
and amman it's kind of funny but the
pawn being on h6 may be
super important for rook h7 defending
the seventh rank
that's crazy but that's uh that's the
foresight you need in a position like
this because
it's all hands on deck in terms of
defense keep in mind the time let's not
forget there's an extra minute here for
roberto but i'm loving
levy's position i know that it you know
the engine is sort of favoring black
here but
i just feel like white's center is so
solid and you know you might say hey
there's a pass pawn on on the a file
passport in the h-file
well yeah but neither of those pawns can
actually move right now what's more
important is why didn't he play king c2
just get out of the middle of the board
and he must have
forgotten that that pawn could be
captured because of the pawn structure
being the way that it was it seemed like
my pawns are invincible you can't take
those they're protected by pawns and yet
one goes down
the bishop should probably move away
from c5 you don't have to just yet
because
this pin still exists but that bishop
should move away and honestly
i still don't mind white's position
because they're all these attacking
chances
all right robert how many pawns can levy
lose before you don't like his position
well he's threatening rook takes a6
check and queen b8 checkmate so bishop
a7 that's a good choice
what about the bishop sack on a6 can you
get away with it
i don't know if it works but i'm looking
at thinking
if we take on a6 you capture back my
rook lens they're
threading queen b8 checkmate i'm turning
b1 to a1
things of that nature d5 becomes a
possibility
it's just a wild position yeah just show
your checkmate queen b8 mate uh which is
easy to overlook in positions like that
and king e1 now he gets out of the way
but i'm worried that he might be
choosing the wrong side here
hey look you mentioned it earlier uh
rook h7 like just
put that rook on that seventh rank and
you'll always have it there and there it
is i mean
robert that's uh the grand master uh
foresight you saw that move earlier and
now it comes into play
it was necessary to see that because
this pin on the a file the pressure on
the b file
now your queen is free to go if you want
to and you can also use the g
file to your advantage i don't see how
white plans to attack here
you put the pawn c4 but you don't have a
pawn going to b5 and in fact c4
eliminates your sacrifice on a6 i think
you could play a move like rook g8 you
could also play
h5 h4 h3 h2 and go queen that pawn
seriously h5 might be like the most
annoying move to face because you got
4.3 seconds you have to identify
a way to deal with a very simple plan uh
roberto's got a solid position i think
he knows he's not getting mated by any
sacrifice here
that's why the position is like minus
five you know that's almost like being
up a rook
uh and the reason the position is is uh
as bad as that
is because the king is sort of i mean it
went to d2 now it's back to e1 is it
going to go to f2
well then you know queen e7 might make
it go back to e1 so there's no safe
place for that king
and you've got and there's h5 this is
tough to meet
and he's going to sacrifice an a6 out of
necessity or he doesn't really want to
but he's going to have to just to create
some threats
but you've also look at your bishop on
e3 it's behind the pawns
and you needed the threat of d5 at some
point to do anything and now that
knight's coming into d5 and
well that's yeah so you mentioned it
he's sacking out a necessity and you
know why
because black was about to play knight
d5 which is pretty much resignable
if black achieves that ruins everything
in your position
and basically fish basics doesn't work
now it's gonna work never
right bishop comes back to d2 it needs
to go to a5 to b6 that's a long journey
and queen b7 offering a queen exchange
not so fast queen
is a very good move now the queen should
go to g7 all the way to the other side
of the board because you're threatening
a mate
attack on g1 and i think rook e to e7 is
also one of those moves that just
just covers everything and gets over to
beast and he does play it it's just
safe moves he doesn't need to be
anything except safe
in this position yeah i'm looking at how
to counter-attack you're just saying hey
just be safe
different look at this bishop b6 that's
scary and he's six seconds he doesn't
know that much times
he took that well i i mean at this point
you have to take
he's losing he's definitely losing this
rook a8 here
he barely has moves and he lost his
queen because he
unfortunately took things and levy broke
it open credit to levy for staying in
this
and now they're in a bullets ground
queen aids mate oh
check me missed king c now he's going to
see it though he's going to see
now he sees it and he wins by
resignation and
wow that was a critical moment because
levy takes a lead
and we're actually going to head into
our halfway break
that game was roberto's for the taking
and yet
he took on b6 and that's what cost him
that game of mine what a turnaround
that was insane that was crazy
i don't know what the evaluation of that
game was
but it felt like it was in double digits
like that that game was over
done there was an extra piece on the
board there was actually two past pawns
there were a couple moves from becoming
brand new queens robert
and full credit to levy because i
i have to say roberto missed something
there but
levy stayed in that game he had like one
second for
20 moves or something robert i don't
know how he did it but he's leading this
match right now
honestly can levy get the white pieces
to every game of roberto with black
because we've seen some wild affairs
there was a rook for
two and then three pawns and then
finally a victory for roberto we just
saw that last game where black was up
three pawns then a piece with the past
pawns and yet
levy was the one who broke through and
delivered a checkmating attack so what a
wild
state of games we've seen thus far we're
gonna be right back for more from this
i'm not jim speeches championship final
brought to you by chess.com
and we are back we have the players on
screen here roberto
doing a little chiropractic exercises
cracking the neck
levy he's sitting there just wondering
what that game was
and amman you have the information for
us because it was wild the time was
ticking down
what happened there at the end crazy i
mean you can just see the evaluation bar
um almost uh you know fully fully down
there it was -10
you know and i i think just simple
simply h4
you mentioned it as almost a joke like
black's position is so solid
he can play h4h3h2h1 well i think that
was actually the answer robert
that's all that needed to happen here
the the amount of moves that are
required to make a threat
for levy um it's just too many you know
you need the rook you need the bishop
you need the bishop again and
at that time that pawn it's getting a
queen and it's with jeff with 1.9
seconds
it's just crazy to me that he was able
to turn that game around
and actually win it uh you know we'll
see
how recovered uh roberto is after that
shocking defeat well he looks locked in
i'm looking at his
expressions on his face he's ready to
play and we have another
dutch we saw that earlier roberto had a
great position he actually won a pawn
and then levy did well to hold that in
the end game but i think that roberto
has no problems repeating
based on the position he was able to
obtain yeah he's
saying you know you want to give me a
pawn and you know i'm either going to
win
or draw that game for the rest of the
match uh yeah sign me up i'll be here
all day
and we have a difference in this game a5
played by levy instead of
knight a6 which we saw in the previous
game and this looks
more normal because black is able to
counter on the queen side
although white can still play the move
d5 trade off those dark square bishops
and i'm much more concerned about
black's king than anything
yeah and i think the move b4 is a bit
reactive like after a4 you almost feel
like you're it's compulsory you have to
do something with the b-pawn either you
take or you push but
completely agree there um robert d5
seemed like the move because you you
basically lock the
uh the bishop back from the b7 square
trade those pieces and you know what
you're trading the pieces before
levy has a chance to play e6 queen e7 so
there's no queen coming over to g7 to
trade as well
it's actually just getting rid of the
only piece in front of black's king
all of a sudden we might see a quick
turnaround in an attack and even when
black plays e6 there's this thematic
idea of playing d5 sometimes it costs
you a pawn but you get the activity
and roberto continuing to play very
solid chess b4 then a3 locking up the
queen side
and perhaps that a4 pawn which is trying
to break open the position is just going
to become a target as the game continues
because it's not a square that's away
from the remaining black pawns
and can be attacked in the future yeah
no
this is a3 he doesn't want to see a3
from black at any point basically he
wants to connect the pawn chain
uh these guys are all working together
c5 something they will all defend each
other in d6 so i like this a lot more
from levy he's changing things up
from a previous position that didn't go
his way we see the adaptations
i wonder if that's something he looked
at in the break because a5 a4
and he looks like he wants to get the
knight to d7 instead of a6
i think that's much improved certainly
is and again
white can consider this d5 move it's
thematic you want to
think about it every single turn he is
50 seconds ahead in the clock roberto
and so he can play d5 but i would think
before making because that changes the
entire nature of the game
i just think that you have to do
something you can't just sit and wait
and
shuffle your pieces around you need to
play d5 you just played rook to d1
and um i'll just put a move on the board
here rook
f e1 um knight d7 and bishop f1 just to
illustrate
a point that you brought up earlier this
is a way for white to avoid
the trade here and i'll just play king
h8 to you know display the intentions
you bring the knight back of course you
don't want to lose the bishop for the
knight
if you're black and then white might get
a move like e4
in and then bring the bishop back and it
might look like you know
robert why would i waste like five six
moves just to not trade these bishops
that's how powerful it is he doesn't uh
do that at all but that is the main
consideration to keep the bishop on g2
he says look knight d2 i'm fine going
for trades what do you make of this
position
he's fine going for trades absolutely
shocking you know i've never heard that
from his own mouth but
that's what roberto does he sticks to
his guns here and look at this position
the a4 pawn still a target e4 an idea
for white at some point but black could
counter with f4 we saw
levy doing that in an earlier game where
he played f4 even before
white pushed the e pawn so he may
consider that and i
actually think that white has a very
stable position and it's harder for
black to play
precisely because of that a4 pawn your
rook on a8 would love to go rook to e8
but then you drop the pawn on the spot
so you need to figure out what to do
with respect to that a4 pawn yeah and uh
i was gonna say
there are a few uh other thematic moves
speaking of d5 for white
uh d5 for black or b5 for black even
though it's a pawn sacrifice both of
these moves make a lot of sense because
you're trying to entice the move c5
and slowly but surely this bishop on b2
it's getting worse and worse that more
pawns are appearing
on the dark squares and that's a dark
square bishop so
keep in mind that as this game
transitions closer and closer to an
end game robert those bishops i think
black is going to be happier with the
way that the pawn complexion is
developing
and you've control over the e4 square so
no pawn breaking the center
you're absolutely correct the bishop
won't staring into its own pawn the
bishop one g7 can even
switch diagonals to h6 at some point and
if you play c5 for white then black can
consider b5 closing down that side of
the board so roberto keeping the tension
alive that's very smart
he can play knight f3 now because that
knight would like to jump into e5 with
tempo
since the rook is there and actually at
some point c takes d5 queen c6
looks like an option so i would start
with knight f3 right now with the
idea of knight e5 and if not cd queen c6
the rook on 8 the pawn c7
the pawn a4 all under attack
love the move knight f3 from you and
roberto the
the roberts and the robertos teaming up
here rook f7
it just looks like knight f3 is the
perfect reaction to that move you're
immediately threatening two moves that
are just gonna cause us to go back to f8
and then as you said pawn takes pawn
potentially opening up on the c7 pawn
so rook f7 i wasn't a big fan of that
move from levy especially because
the the position is sort of closed off
there's no open file it's not like
you're doubling on the open f file
everything's closed there for the moment
so it seems like
levy is a little bit caught uh playing
defense here
a4 pawn c7 pawn are things you're gonna
have to watch for the rest of the game
and just the control of the c file in
addition to the c7 pawn being
a target is so nice for white and once
the knight gets to e5
black has a trouble taking it you can
even bring your bishop to capture your
knight to capture it but after
d takes e5 at some moment the d5 pawn is
a weakness
that has to have an eye kept on it so i
think that levy's in big trouble and
look at the clock an
extra minute for roberto levy has done
pretty well on the clock in some games
in others he's been down to the waning
seconds and still wins like in
game four that we saw just before the
break but that extra minute
should play a part in this one b5 by the
way and getting the knight to c6 also
looks good
i heard everything he said there partner
just had my uh headphones unplugged for
a sec so
trust me i i agree with everything i
agree with everything you made fantastic
points and you know what
that's why robert's a grand master guys
listen to him
honey and i'm jumping right back in here
uh
what the heck is queen e8 rookie seven
this is like uh one of these types of
batteries on an e-file but it's
completely closed off
it is and you would like to see c takes
d5 and then
the situation open up but even that
should favor white i actually like the
move c takes d5
because you're opening the c file the c6
squares your knights from taking
and i had mentioned i know you heard me
but i'll just reiterate that b5
for white instead of pawn e3 was an
option to plant the knight of c6 so
perhaps roberto will regret that to some
extent
because if the knights get traded he
can't put a knight in c6 it's gone from
the board
yep knight g4 and i think that if we get
mass mass trades for example like taking
on d5 taking on e5
um even if the position is equal or
roberto could even be down a pawn in
some cases
just that a four pawn d5 upon c7 there's
gonna be so many weaknesses
and white's pawn structure is intact
everything's covered
um i think that roberto has the better
position here quite clearly
and it's also trending towards one of
those end games where
you might have one extra pawn and trying
to press an advantage home
and roberto retreats his knight to f3 if
we can just bring up the analysis board
for a second
if he left that knight in e5 and had
played rook to d1 or f1 to d1 just an
example
after knight takes e5 pawn takes e5
white's position is still excellent
you've been attacking the d5 pawn you're
hitting the c spire the a4 pawn is still
weak exactly what you were talking about
so he brings the knight back which is
not a bad move
it just is curious decision and i wonder
where he's going to go to next
yeah i think uh he just looks at the
move knight g4 and says you know what
i don't want to even validate that move
by going allowing a trade at all i want
to say
i can kick that knight with h3 then it
goes back and then i can maybe return to
the e5 square
on my terms h6 has been played by levy
this looks like a nice
tall move you don't need to do anything
crazy he just needs to get a move off
and
now he's uh he's evened up the the time
on the clock as well
and look at roberto this is the most
roberto move of them all queen c6
just trading queens but he's taking
advantage of black's h6 move
that g6 pawn is tender and so queen c6
yeah the queens can trade the d5 pawns
under attack
everything is sort of vulnerable in
black's camp but if the queens get
traded that rook on c6 will attack the
g6 pawn and then rook f to c1 next the
c7
pawn's in big trouble yeah and there was
actually a sort of mini threat rook
takes e3
in the previous position so queen c6 not
only a good move for many other reasons
but also
getting out of that as well can you even
refuse the queen trade here queen
d8 queen takes g6 i don't think there's
a good way to do it unless
yeah like you're going rook d7 or
something ridiculous but uh how quickly
did he play queen takes queen there
robert
and i don't think he needed to that's
the thing is he did it and it's still
good for white
but i'm guessing he had more if he had
spent some time but he is so quick to
trade the queens
and he also is up 50 seconds of cloud
rick after c1
rook c rook takes b6 wins a pawn so he's
actually taking this game
he should be um f4 why is that move
played you might see the evaluation bar
just
you know taking off uh on the runway
there well he just has to do something
the position is locked up we might even
see knight takes e3 here
as crazy as that move is just because he
needs to he needs to have
something to play for it's a terrible
terrible game positionally speaking
yeah f4 is one of those hey maybe
roberto's pre-moving some kind of rook
move and i can win a pawn this way
levi knew his position was very bad so
he essentially was resigning
and just trying to create a tactical
opportunity and for roberto credit to
him because
we do criticize some of his decisions we
talk about how he could be a bit
too solid in some situations but he
never
let go of his advantage so he had the
lead
throughout that one he just ground levy
down to the point where he had no good
moves to look at
yeah and you we we've talked as you
mentioned about uh being too solid but
that's an example of where his solid
play got him the win
maybe easier than you know an attacking
player might have so that's it paying
off there and
uh this line actually kind of
interesting i'm just going to go back
for a second here
um talk about this move bishop to d7 it
looks so weird like why would you bring
your bishop
out and then immediately bring it back
into d7 and play e6 and lock it in i
mean
don't we all play bishop h7 well after
bishop h7
usually white often goes for this this
move e6
and it looks crazy but after this these
pieces are all kind of
locked away on the king side you see
that evaluation bar creeping creeping up
there
and it's going to get better and better
so that's why roberto played the bishop
back
which looks completely like an
anti-caracan
could never be roberto playing that
bishop h7 e6 line
absolutely never no way if you showed me
his name i would say it's a forgery
he's not playing variations like that he
would much rather have
his pieces a bit restricted look at that
bishop on d7 kind of
staring into its pawns then allow some
kind of tactical sequence of that nature
and i respect that a lot about roberto
style yes
there are some moments maybe he should
go for more but in the opening stage he
knows
the positions that he wants to strive
for he ends up accomplishing that
and look at levy playing f4 g4 this is
fine look at the evaluation bar it still
thinks white's doing well
but from a strategic point of view it's
difficult to throw all your pieces
forward
and if you don't find that knockout or
that way to
infiltrate in the position you start
getting frustrated and there's no taking
moves like f4 and g4 back
that's true but if there's one thing
i've learned from this
this opening is that you can never count
out levy rosman
based on the evaluation that he was able
to withstand
the last time that they played that's
true he did survive a tough one there it
is a two and a half two and a half match
these
players thus far even on the scoreboard
playing a pretty level match
throughout the only thing that has not
been level and
there's no surprise here is the clock
yep
this is a common common theme
commonality it's that full minute ahead
for roberto we had that
you know flash of hope early on when
levy had the
advantage but i think that lasted about
10 seconds and
you know he hasn't gone back to it after
bishop b5 i'm looking at the move queen
to d4 as a potential uh
move like let's say queen takes d4
bishop takes b5
check throw that move in before you take
the queen back for a nice little tactic
that's awesome we had one like that in
the greg vs levy match when i was
talking about some queen b6 move or
something
so that's a good spot by you the queen
is the only piece defending the bishop
that bishop would be captured with check
so after queen d4 black actually has to
move the queen back
and instead levy plays c3 but roberto
quickly
gets rid of that light square bishop
this is turned from a caracon
into a french-like idea and what do you
think about the bathtub formation for
white
uh i think that generally speaking if
the
the middle of the board is opened up i'm
maybe less of a fan
um the knight's gonna come to e7 i
wasn't necessarily
sure if knight c6 was the best way to go
but bishop e3 if you
basically it all comes down to the e5
pawn if you can secure that pawn
and get castled safely f5 is going to
happen but
for now roberto he's getting developed
but i'm not liking how many tempi he's
giving levy
and the easy development that white's
able to get and where is black gun at
castle because look at a4 i was about to
say if you castle queen side
here comes a four b4 etc and if you
castle king side well you don't really
need to me to tell you what's going to
happen look where the pawns are they're
going to start going up the board
however
castle and king side if white plays g5
knight f5 is available
and if white tries to play f5 that e5
pawn loses a very important defender
it's pawn and the king's on e1 still so
ho ho d4
by roberto that is a tactical move
trying to solve his problems
giving himself the d5 square that's a
french-like solution to this position
although i do believe white can take the
pawn and claim a legitimate edge
wow that is a very surprising move like
how important is that center pun usually
that is the
uh you know the backbone of the position
here whether it's a french or a karo
khan it's all about that d5 pawn
and just playing d4 giving up a central
pawn like that
that's it's clear to me that roberto was
thinking about castling after the movie
a4 he's probably like i want to castle
king side but he was looking at moves
like knight d4 by white
blockading maybe and just f5 f6 not the
type of position he wants to defend but
robert can you give up a pawn and then
think for like a minute afterwards this
seems unprepared
i wouldn't advise that but roberto is
very strong player so i would say he
knows what he's doing so
it's clear that he also is kind of
confused at what's happening based on
the fact that he just gave away upon
his thinking for a long time so the good
news for him is that levy's king is in
the center the bad news is kind of
everything else
that he's no longer up on time he's down
a pawn those pawns are all
defended he can't castle in either
direction without seeing an attack
happen
so yeah i think levy is much much better
here and playing very well
knight d5 now that to me is a logical
follow-up i mean giving up a pawn like
that well hey let's actually use the
square
that that pawn used to be on for some of
the pieces that are remaining
knight d5 hitting the bishop looking at
that f-pawn again this is one thing i
mentioned that epon needs to be secure
before you can play f5 so i don't think
that we're gonna be seeing
you know moves like f5 punched in
immediately knight takes c6 played and
is he just gonna keep this bishop and
and prevent castling with bishop c5
that's what i'm looking at
oh it's going from bad to worse if that
bishop gets to c5 you cannot castle
it will not be legal and that bishop can
go into d6 the white pawn can go to c4
to kick the knight out of d5
this is this is horrible position yeah
this is
um really really bad anything but bishop
c5
would surprise me here because bishop c5
you get into d6 you stop
castling uh long castle i know it looks
insane but
hey there it is you gotta do something
that gets the rook to the open file
i mean it's an attempt queen a6 what do
you think of long castle robert
yeah open file for now but after bishop
d6 how open is that file i'm just going
to plant my bishop there if you exactly
exchange which
you may feel obligated to do because
your position is that bad at this point
but that's still going to be good for
white very clearly and if you don't
sacrifice your rook for the bishop one
d6
then my bishop is planted in your face
and i'm still going to go attack you and
probably going to succeed yeah there's
either bishop e6 there's queen asics
long castling by white uh looks like
there's no pawns in front of the king
but
they're there they're just a little bit
further away the main thing is that
roberto has no way to
come close to attacking a white king on
c1 so
i think levy's king could be safe on e2
f2
c1 it's it's up to him he's got a great
position here
and despite only being up one pawn he's
got a serious advantage
and f6 is a good move he needs to do
something like that and levy down
half a minute on the clock and that's
going to be
roberto's chance and can he take on e5
he can't take a second time because
queen a6 check
will be a problem so yeah you're not
even winning the pawn then you're
opening the f file the rook on f1 says
hello
happy to be here and that's just well
that file is gonna be tough because you
can't even challenge it he's like hello
happy to be here
you can't even say hello back how rude
and yeah this is a sad looking position
and this would be a very big win for
levy because roberto just evened up the
score
and if levi can take this one and it's a
very one-sided game i might add
that he'll be thrilled about his chances
yeah king b7
now i am a fan of this one the reason is
that it finally gets rid of queen a6
that move has been lingering in the
position for a while it's finally gone
um as as winning as this game is you
know
as much as the engine is saying uh wrap
it up you know
pack it up go home i still think that
roberta has some outside chances
as there are some lingering tactics and
knight against bishop if we get to a
certain type of end game
there's still some hope in my opinion
well he plays queen f7 doesn't want to
sacrifice the exchange which is what i
was thinking about on the d6 square
yeah it's not clear how white breaks
through and just checkmate's
black if that's the case for now for
example f5 comes to mind my queen's
enough seven
i want to go win some of your pawns in
the king side open the board up
and f5 there he goes that's at least a
chance and 45 seconds left for levy
yeah and you know if you see move like
b5 which might be a good response
you know there's rook c8 the king can
hide on a8
uh if you open the position up over
there it might get worse and worse for
your king remember as soon as f takes g4
later on
there's queen takes on f4 with a check
trading this can definitely still flip
around despite that big evaluation
and rook ca played down to 35
seconds is levy and this is a complex
position i see the eval bar
is sky high but i don't believe that and
i don't think the players know that
levy knows he's better he's up in pawn
but look at his king on c1 it's now in
the open and if you take on c6 rook take
c6
that rook patrols the sixth rank you go
to b6 if it wants the other rook can
come to c8
and then white is the one who seems like
he's less safe
yeah and i mean the f4 pawn is loose
here and
i think that taking on c6 is sort of
like a pseudo threat but you could react
with king a8
the queen covers d7 checkmate so there's
ways to just play pawn takes fun and he
does that
wow that is a brave choice and a good
choice and he plays c4
kicking the knight can you just keep
going knight takes f4 the queen on f7
does defend the b7 square like you said
but i am worried about the black king i
have to be honest that looks quite scary
although at this point you've committed
to it you probably have to take knight
takes four
i would do it quickly i mean at the end
of the day we're getting in a bullet
time screen but i don't like that move
because now
pawn takes pawn is a winning threat okay
but he plans not on b6 and if c
oh wait c5 queen a4 is just pawn digs b6
the queen is defended
on b3 very importantly otherwise black
would get away with this tactically
because the white queen would be in but
you know what he might be doing is after
pawn takes pawn i think he's going to
play king takes
that's what's crazy after c5 maybe you
just go to knight takes a4
wait what's happening now because wait
this rook let's see one's hanging so you
can't play cb5 and now rook takes c4
just take it right oh we lose oh i
didn't even but we did d3 broke is loose
two
wow what a weird position i was gonna
say queen e4 looks like a great move but
c5 the counter punch hits the knight and
defends the rook on d3
and he wins the time he wins and levy
shakes his head and gives a little laugh
there
but that was maybe payback for the
earlier game where roberto
had levy on the clock and lost that game
up a piece but i don't even know what to
say
wow robert we have seen i mean levy time
and time again it's that time pressure
and whether he can handle it we were
saying that game should have been
over from the beginning but i was
maintaining that outside chance because
the the knight on d5 was so strong and
although levy was prosecuting his
advantage
he was using a lot of time to do so and
it became tougher and tougher
to handle a complicated position with
low time on the clock that's going to be
for any player doesn't matter how good
you are
at calculating with low time i mean the
point is we all play better when we have
more time to calculate
right illustrated by what we were doing
it's hard to juggle
the complicated position in front of you
and the clock situation so levy was
trying to figure it out
and then you can forget about your time
just how little you have remaining
and for levy that's a big big loss there
he's now down a point
he will not have the advantage in bullet
like he has in previous matches i think
that the players
are about even in bullet their ratings
are both around 2 800.
so for levy you don't want to see this
tilt out of hand you want to
just say okay this match has been back
and forth we both are playing
pretty exciting chess let's just keep
calm here this is still
a match we're in the first time patrol
it feels like we've been here forever
honestly
but this is the first time control it's
true there's so much
chess ahead um however you speak about
that first time control this is very
likely going to be the last game
in that first time control so i mean the
ideal situation
if you're levy rosman is obviously
leveling this match going into the break
equal because we've had some insane
games
both tactically on the clock
stylistically it's been a real treat so
far but
uh for these players maybe on both ends
to go in uh
evened up maybe that's the best that
they can ask for because it's been a
rollercoaster of emotions for both of
them so far
and look at roberto he's trying to
figure out his emotions right now
he's got his head in his hands not like
this
not like this indeed and well maybe like
this because he just scored the victory
so
he wants more of that and that's the way
i like his position
with the white pieces the pin on the c6
knight but
levy is ahead on the clock so there's
something about this queen's gamut
accepted
that is in levy's wheelhouse and despite
the
good center for white the development
the pin on the knight and c6
the eval bar says hey it's completely
equal which actually
to me means that black should be in very
good shape because it looks good for
white and yet it's not that great
the central pawns could be in some
trouble i mean yeah
white has a pin but you fail to realize
that black has two of them and you know
more more pins more wins that's that's
what they say robert so
g4 he actually had to eliminate one of
them because look at the pressure that
was mounting
bishop takes f3 the pawn was going to be
loose on d4 and black is one move away
from
choosing which direction he's going to
castle i don't think he's going to pick
queen side with bishop takes c6
available but
as soon as he plays king side castling
there's an e pawn and a deep on
potentially that we're going to be
hanging in the center of the board
yeah bishop g6 now hitting the e4 pawn
so that's the threat if you castle
bishop takes c3 followed by bishop takes
e4 will be a bit of a problem so i'm
expecting queen to e2
and roberto down a minute on the clock
so something in this opening
not going the way he anticipated or
wanted and now
he's the one in some time trouble so
this feels like levy's game
to strike back it's the final game most
likely of the time patrol they're just
over three minutes left
and plenty of time left in the player's
clocks so i think
that levy you know if he's careful if he
plays accurately here
he should be able to obtain an advantage
based on the loose squares
on white's king side totally agree um i
think just
castle here there's not many other moves
that i'm thinking of there might be
tactics like queen f4 is another move
that that i would consider here but
my instinct is just get castled and then
all the tactics will present themselves
whether it's
a rook to d8 uh whether it's queen f4
to follow up i'm not sure if there's any
need for queen f4 immediately
is if it's such a strong move but i'm
just thinking castling here as a
baseline move
got to be good for for levy although
your queen f4 move
tempting tactically because the e4 pawn
hit a second time
the knight on c3 can be removed as a
defender and it's pinned so it's not a
true defender at the moment
so that's probably what levy's thinking
about but he needs to keep that lead on
the clock
both moves look very good you kind of
need to choose a plan
and maintain the pressure not just on
the board but also
on the clock as well yeah i think queen
f4 might be knight
92 might be required just to actually
keep that pawn
um one thing that i'll point out is a
potential way
that um levy's position does not end up
looking good he does play queen f4 i was
going to say a position where
white gets to play f3 and this bishop on
g6 somehow feels completely locked out
of the game
so look for something like that as
roberto's gonna need to untangle here
but knight d2 do we have any other moves
here robert
i only see knight d2 otherwise you lose
a pawn he does play the move
and black can play h5 because he is not
castled he can choose to play h5
but then the white king darts to the
queen side and that could be a problem
for black because your king has nowhere
to hide
yeah you can't match that castle and
queen side for black doesn't mean
immediately bishop takes c6
queen a6 ideas so finally he decides
let's just get castle here
get out of the middle of the board um
i'm looking at things
like queen e3 uh as a way to maybe
stabilize the center and get out of this
pin
from the bishop on g6 and the queen on
d3 i don't like it all there's going to
be rookie
bishop g6 all hitting that tender square
i think we just get out of the way and
offer a queen trade i don't think he'll
be uh too upset with that there robert
and takes pawn takes back strengthens
the center it does but it
gets rid of your f3 idea so the bishop
on g6 is at least happier
that there's no pawn coming f3 is
stabilized so queen e3 is played
no surprise there ahmad you called it
roberto takes the opportunity as he
typically does to trade queens
and now the question for levy is do you
trade on e3 or do you drop your queen
back
either to d or f6 and say let's keep
these queens on the board
right and i think it's reasonable to
keep the queens on the board
i mean queen takes e3 i don't think
there's any problem with but
i like the decision to keep the queens
on i think the center is still very
tender here
there's gonna be a rook d8 and uh
depending on where the white king goes
no matter where robert i'm actually
looking at a lot of spicy ways to react
like
uh if you go king side maybe something
like f5 h5 these pawn breaks start to
come to mind as a way to open up the
middle of the board
and potentially where that king is going
to end up and he chooses knight b3 first
to defend d4 but you're absolutely
correct the king for white
doesn't have a clear home it probably
will end up on the
oh i don't know i was gonna say the king
side but now i'm not certain it's like
how do you choose which way the king
goes first of all black's turn so black
can play a6 i don't think white really
wants to take
on c6 the queen recaptures hitting the
e4 pawn once more
but what else is there to do in this
position i feel like you could easily
kick white back and then play rook d8
and things like that and
yeah that's a start yeah and this
position i think first of all
um it's been a very well played game by
both
but i think levy is slowly out playing
here he's got the two bishops
i think we'll see something like rook d8
um he might be waiting to see
where roberto is going to place his king
before he makes a very committal
decision and goes all out
um with you know something like h5 or
something like a5 i think
a5 could be a move that he plays
regardless though in a position like
this
and you're definitely not castling once
a5 is on the board but you're threading
a4 for black to win the d4 point i like
your move
and he plays e5 which i don't like
nearly as much it does help the dark
square bishop out
because if white plays d5 then that
bishop can eventually get to the c5
square
but i feel like this does help white at
least feel
safer in the center of the board instead
of hanging upon
you may give up some squares but you're
not going to lose material and what do
you think about
d5 knight a5 i think that might be
levy's intention trying to like
immediately take the dark squares um
basically you want to play bishop to c5
but
you can't do that because the knight on
b3 so knight a5 looking to trade
and then making sure that after a3 you
don't have to take your bishop and give
it up for the knight on c3
the whole point of e5 as you mentioned
take the dark squares so
e5 knight a5 looks like a way that you
can actually still keep that dark square
bishop because
d5 knight e7 i might just go a3 and i
don't know if you want to give that that
bishop up
yeah you'd probably prefer not to but
white i was about to say white's king's
still in the center and then he castles
queenside which is the least roberto
move ever and bishop c5 for black
just wins material this is
just not acceptable there's no knight b5
there's no knight e2
and there's no other piece that can save
that knight we might even see him just
add the pressure
levy that is with rook d8 and 30 seconds
left
this is a tactical position just to say
the least
and a dead lost tactical position for
white it is
an incredible evaluation there levy has
got this game and roberto knows time
ticking down
the five plus one time is expiring
robert and looks like we're gonna have a
level match what a decision
levy played a very good game and had a
better position but
to castle queenside that is did somebody
take the mouse from roberto there
that's not somebody should have taken
the mess from roberto before he castled
i'll say that
that's not him right he likes to play
solidly he doesn't want to
open up the position and get attacked he
must have overlooked the bishop c5 move
and now
well there must be a bunch of different
winning ways can i just take on d4 and
play c6
c6 just game over yeah this is winning a
piece you have these ideas like 97
knight f6 discovered attack but the
queen takes both of them and that's
going to be a
little mic drop there from levi rosman
as you see him get a clean
and very very convincing win
at the end of this portion you mentioned
he should just relax after that last
game
remember that these games are all very
competitive he is giving them
up on time sometimes but look at the way
he can bounce back
and i think this is an insanely
competitive match
right now and what a tactical affair as
well
it's been a great match thus far both
sides trading blows
and i would say that levy his time
management has been better in some of
the games he still suffers
from that same losing too much time
early doesn't conserve enough for
more of the problematic stages later in
the game but he has
proven that he is every bit roberto's
equal thus far
on roberto's side of things that last
game was not a good one from him he
would like to take that one back
he's made some solid choices that
honestly probably cost him a half point
in that earlier game
but overall both sides trading blows
playing really good chess
i don't see anyone as the favorite going
forward it's really a toss-up
yeah absolutely we're about to get into
the three minute portion after this but
first we're gonna jump to break robert
because we gotta decompress after that
and hopefully when we come back we have
just as exciting games to look forward
to
uh be right back after this now that
we're after the break we are getting set
for 45 minutes of three minute plus one
second increment blitz chess a mod
that's a faster time control
that is the more normal time control
events like title tuesday
use that time control so what do you
think the players
it's custom for them but it's hard to
adjust sometimes when you have two extra
minutes to start
now making your way back to three-minute
territory
yeah that's a great point robert i think
that the players are gonna be a little
more comfortable in this format it's a
bit more familiar to them
it's closer to not only three-minute
chess but it is the as you mentioned
exact
time control of things like title
tuesday which i'm sure both of these
players have participated in before so
i think we might see the players a
little bit more comfortable with their
time management
but it also means that whatever you know
time
issues you may have had in five minutes
i think they're going to be more
pronounced
in the three minute portion all of a
sudden you know getting down one two
minutes
that's more than half your clock robert
you got to be careful you can't have
those
opening things you need to be well
prepared so that way if your opponent
plays something unexpected you're not
just sitting there
twirling your thumbs wondering what to
do next you don't have time to calculate
in that manner
and it's much closer to bullet chest in
earlier stages so we'll see how the
players
do here i think that levy should have
the momentum he just won that final game
and the players trading off victory so
neither side
can take any real lead just a game here
a game there
but now that we're in the three minute
portion we'll see what happens
glad we got the close-up there of uh it
looks like
levy was just uh oiling up the system
there getting those eye drops in
making sure everything's uh working good
you're gonna need those uh those eyes i
hear they're important for
for some of these chess matches yeah
every now and then you need to use those
but
h6 we've seen this before of g4 the
bishop went back to d7
and roberto goes right back to that i
wonder if roberto will stop
playing the carol khan in a match
against lawrence trent he was like
lawrence almost retired
mike carroll and levy kind of doing
something similar
feels like he game after game has a good
position
yeah he's really sticking it to him it's
a very aggressive style
i think that it's probably something
roberto looked at because if he's
playing it again
uh he knows life is going for every
single game
and he has to be prepared so i think
it's doubtlessly something he looked at
in the break
and he must have something slightly
different because he knows the exact
setup
that levy's going to go for what are we
going to see are we going to see like a
c5 and there and there we go c5 move
again
but if he goes for that bishop b5 we saw
how quickly that backfired last time
what is going to be different this time
so queen d4 can be played i wonder if
levy looked at it
just based on time usage thus far it
doesn't look like he did
so queen d4 is that tactical possibility
either way
roberto had a tough position now we have
the same exact
setup yeah the rook captures the queen
went to d3 bishop to e3
i don't really like this from roberto's
perspective
yeah he's just repeating it again i'm
still waiting for
you know basically what's gonna happen
after the knights develop what's going
to be queen d3 if you're levi rosman
why are you changing your moves at all
you pretty much had a crush
right out of the opening so if 97 bishop
e3 queen a5 a4
i'm just waiting for roberto's new move
because
i can't imagine that you just sacked the
pawn with d4 again
that didn't end up very well he won the
game actually but it was not a good
position for him let's put it that way
so what can you do here can you play
queen b6 just to attack the
b2 pawn but after queen b6 rook f2 for
white
yeah you attacked the pawn i defended a
second time then played bishop e3 next
anyway
i don't know what black should do and
neither does roberto because he repeated
the opening
and now is spending time that's the
worst thing to do in the three-minute
portion i mentioned how
important time is going to be and if i'm
levy i'm playing a4 here and yeah
just show me show me what you got queen
c7 there we go
that's the new move and i think that he
made that up about four seconds ago
extremely logical when the knight goes
from c6 to replace the queen on a5
now the c4 square and the b3 square
because the
white pawn is on a4 rather than a2 so
there are some opportunities
for black i'm not sure where white's
king is going you don't particularly
want to castle queenside
when you push your pawn to a4 so you can
castle queenside
it's just as risky yeah it it is a
little bit more open but
as you mentioned still possible uh the
other thing is just walking your king
to the king side king f2 king g2 is
possible as well
queen c7 though um putting pressure on
e5 dissuiting the f5 move and also
levy is probably waiting for black to
commit his king before he decides
how he wants to advance his pawns
further yeah the e5 score very important
here
also bishop c5 not possible because of
knight takes e5 and the queen on c7
will stare down at that bishop there so
the bishop c5 bishop b6 what you want to
do
can't do it and i think black should
castle king side and then push the f
pawn
yep king side and then either f6 or f5
probably f6
to guarantee the position starts to open
up we see b4
f6 is looking nearly automatic when the
king is sitting on
f2 especially if you played b5 here i am
sacrificing the piece it's not even a
real sacrifice i'm winning it back so he
does take on f6
and now the rook lands there the next
rook lands on f8 and i see
white has g5 in his future but that
frees up the f5 square so i don't
love that it's a very committal choice
and i would say practically speaking i
like
black's chances and the clock yep
can't forget about that thing the the
one thing i might say about levy's
position
is a timely b5 will pay off because he
gains control of the e5
square and the d4 square so if you do
that in the right moment
you can combine knight e5 bishop d4
maybe knight d4
and as long as he utilizes the move b5
at the right moment
kicking that knight away actually
neither black knight has anywhere to go
so place b6 which says if you go b5 the
a7 pawn isn't under attack maybe it'll
go knight a5 into c4
i was thinking by the way of d4 for
black we saw him sacrifice upon in the
earlier game
but knight to d5 in this position you
kidding me with that king on g2
and now after b6 the opening of the okay
d4 is just
too tempting with the open diagonal as
well
e4 is screaming here i think even e5 is
probably playable as well
but e4 i mean how are you not playing
move like that he played it last time
and i thought it was
a little bit worse so the idea is
definitely something that he's aware
of but maybe because he had such a bad
position
the last time around he doesn't do d4
this time but d4
i think it's still an opportunity you
just want to get your knight to d5 and
well levy says
get out of here i thought maybe pawn to
e5 there threatening queen g4
would have been an interesting
intermezzo but all of a sudden g5 and
things are exploding on the king side
well actually e5 is still a move and e5
probably was a move even with the rook
hanging on f6 so that was
a good spot by you e5 still going to be
possible
probably next it's going to happen next
yeah next turn no matter what
look at the clock levy down under now 16
seconds counting down he is 17 with the
one second increment but i like black's
chances and i like the position
objectively
mm-hmm yep is he gonna keep pushing the
pawns forward remember obviously he
can't
push d4 knight is gonna be hanging on c4
and the king on g3
covers everything i love the move knight
d6 robert that's fantastic
knight e4 check queen comes in g4 with
check i guess you have to go king h2
after
uh knights e4 so you do survive for the
timing but queen g4 is still possible
there's no background checkmate
after queen g4 queen f7 check the king
slide for ej8 and then knight can block
on g8 so that's
honestly looking like a big attack for
black yeah queen g4 would be the type of
move when you have eight seconds ticking
down
that you're like wait what he's getting
made it wait no he's not oh my god and
then you know the flag
comes in so that would have been a
stellar move there allowing queen f7 is
so tough to do though
agreed but once you realize it's not a
checkmate then you're much more likely
to do it so
queen b8 check is not mate you have the
c8 square under your control so that's
good to keep in mind
but oh it takes the pawn because of that
knight c8 now only move
yeah and mean is is necessary for the
knight on 84
also necessary queen d6 trade that off
immediately
oh no roberto bishop queen d8
oh my gosh oh no g7 it's over he lost
yep gg that one's done
i think honestly he's just he's falling
into this trap of
levy doesn't have that much time so i'm
gonna make a couple quick moves and levy
is so
sharp with the tactics that he was able
to steal that game
when it was going roberto's way very
very impressive it
once again levy with that time taking
down less than five seconds it's like
you know there's uh some something
unlocks in levy's position and levy's
brain that
he plays so much better it feels like
and that's why
he's so comfortable getting into this
time pressure situation you know
we criticize it but at the same time
when he's getting results like that
you can understand why he's feeling okay
getting in time pressure
and roberto clearly looked at this line
because in the previous game
bishop g5 took the knight of six now he
put his queen on a4
and he just plays knight d2 opposite
colored bishops amman you spoke about
this last time around that bishop will
go to g6
and white will push the pawn to f3 your
bishop does not look very good
and white has a dark square bishop to
help maintain
the coverage of the dark squares that
are increasingly vulnerable
and i'm liking the way this is going for
roberta right now this
this looks like a very positional
approach
hassling f3 i think that levy needs to
strike
very very quickly with i don't know if
it's something like e5 that needs to
happen here
okay he plays e5 and immediately just
castling i i don't know this looks good
for roberto positionally speaking
it looks fantastic that bishop on h5 is
terrible and it will never be good you
have to move your knight play pawn f6
then get your bishop to f7 and it's
still not doing anything of note and
okay if you have to take on d4 like this
now it's an
open c file you have double isolated c
pawns
i'll bring a rook to c1 my knight can go
to b3 e4 is so well defended d4 will
similarly be defended
i think black is strategically lost
already yeah i think this is uh
terrible um as an opening for for levy i
don't even think that the
the engine's reflecting how good it is
um things like knife v3 rook81
getting the pieces over there it's not
even about these pawns there's so many
pawns that are loose in the position c6
a7
it's not about those things it's about
maintaining the position queen c2
knight b3 how was he he could have taken
the pawn c6 for free
and he played queensy too because he
didn't want to allow any kind of rook b6
rook left over the king side or
something like that i mean this
is one of those situations where i am
going to say
that maybe he could have and should have
taken the pawn
but i understand why he did this he's
going to play knight b3
he has the queen covering the king side
if needed the rook covers the f3 pawn
since the pawn of g2 is pinned
and the bishop can come back to c1 over
to the king side
of course we like white's position but
it's just so funny that he won't take
upon c6
and instead we'll just bring the queen
back to c2 and i think
we might see something like rook a to e1
and then bishop c1 or bishop c1 first
this bishop's sort of
done its job uh on a3 and unless they're
bringing it into c5
i think bishop c1 and rerouting it to e3
or to f4
makes a lot of sense and i'm not ugh i
can't speak but i will not be surprised
if
white plays g4 himself and says hey that
bishop wants to go back to g6
then i go f4 f5 and i can trap your
bishop or just leave it there
point being the bishop is not very good
so g4 is tempting to me
g4 bishop c1 all these type of moves the
c6 pawn still hangs
if you eventually want to take it yeah
if he ever changes his mind
that's like you know an open offer he's
been he's been accepted in a university
it's it's there if he wants it and
just choose that's what he has to do
he's up a minute on the clock
he can spend some time here use it
wisely and then say
maybe i'll play queen c5 because that
offers a queen tray
yeah he has to make a decision and there
he goes gotta use that minute
to his advantage one thing about the
current position is
with opposite bishops on the board even
if everything goes levi's way i don't
see this game getting
ultra tactical and that's the main way
that i could see this position getting
out of hand
or rebirth and he's just gonna play
queen g3 which hits c7 and threatens
bishop g5 at the same time
so he's just really smoothly playing
this game
no risk whatsoever h6 stops the bishop
g5 ideas
and king h2 i wasn't even looking at
moving my king he does it
is he going to play g4 now is that why
he moves his king over there it looks
like queen g3 queen gg3 and bishop s4 i
i'm feeling a connection between roberto
and myself here
robert really i'm really understanding
these moves king h2 queen g3
just everything under control uh uh this
this this is getting clinical after
bishop f4 here bishop f4
comes with tempo wins the c7 pawn he has
to play that but why was king h2
necessary i guess
yeah it's uh it's just one of those
karpov moves is it going to be bishop c7
here you have to include that one first
rook f2 just just i mean just uh sit
back and admire
i do admire it because i'm just please
take the darn pawns and he's like no you
can't make me
and he's holding steady he can play rook
c1
rook c2 go after the c6 pawn and now he
takes on c7 so he just
decided to do it second and knight d5
nice tactical shot
by legend you see you're messing with
him you're telling him to take a pawn he
finally takes one and there's a tactical
shot already
i mean for a guy let him play his
positional chef well that
singing a poor guy that bishop on g6 is
just a sad sad piece
and levy goes knight of six to try to go
knight h5 and he goes bishop
c1 making sure that his bishop will not
be under any attack knight c5
is a fork and after queen takes d4
there's bishop e3 defending everything
the only thing that saves them i think
is like oh it's gonna say queen a5 but
there's bishop d2 there
so nope nothing nothing's saving that
rook it looks like knight c5 but
uh but the calm rook f to e2
here i like it he is well ahead he also
is up 45 seconds levi's down a pawn
and just not really many good looking
moves at this point
so he can play in this manner and it's
fine it just feels like he does it
too regularly yeah and there's a reason
why i brought up that f3 pawn structure
against the bishop on h5 in this opening
um he's managed to get it so what great
work i have to say that i think that he
did over the break because
whatever he did this is a fantastic
position and levy cannot simply cannot
repeat this there's
no way that he can ever play a position
like this again
no he's gonna have to change his opening
for sure knight h5 hoping for some
tactics if you move your queen the
knight comes to g3
and he goes g4 kicks it out the downside
of that move
is there could be a sacrifice on e4 not
the king is a little open but with rooks
on the e file that's not happening yep
so it's been a very controlled game so
far four seconds
we're going to see probably h4 h5 yeah
and at least the knights in e6 for levy
that hits the d4 now knight g5
could be a sacrifice on f3 or e4 now
knight five forces
for sure running e4 a5 i do like though
a5 a4 loosens up the d4 square
so again we see levees starting to come
to life here with
time ticking down okay d takes c6 should
be good
he does it and
queen c of course queen c5 right of
course
but do you see the eval bar drops a
queen actually queen c5 was a bad move
for some reason
yeah yeah no it's i think e4 by the way
e4 will be sacrificed on as soon as
he gets a move okay well the knights
come to f5 probably
so no of course no sacrifice for you yep
queen trade hey don't forget about those
true he needs up two pawns but levy
still has three seconds left so i like
the way levee's holding on now the f4
square
be careful about that yes levy's doing a
great job here the a pawn is just an
easy target and
most importantly the knight on e6 can't
be touched
so it's just got it's found a great
square where it can stay forever okay
watch out for queen f1 check so you have
to move your rook to d1 when you hang a2
so it brings rook to f2 to defend queen
b8 could be eight okay of course he's
gonna play that move because he trades
the queens off and now he's winning
that's a tactic finding a queen trade
that quickly that's just beautiful stuff
he hangs her up
yep the rook is hanging and roberto gets
it levy laughs
oh my gosh well he's laughing robert
because he that was like
the most in the game that he was the
entire game and then he hangs the rook
it's like oh man i don't even get to
play
and you give your opponent some false
confidence maybe that's what roberto was
really doing
he knew that he had that game he was
just trying to make levy feel good about
the position only to deflate him
at the end but on a serious note i think
he
is just in his own head roberto
he's just trying to make trades and then
he went for h4 h5
and all that stuff and it could have
backfired we saw the eval bar
shake at some point saying black has a
tactic here it was overlooked and
now we go back to the keracon if i'm
roberto's coach if i'm his friend
and i have his number i text him during
the break saying maybe you gotta go to
something else it has not been working
and now white has space on the queen
side first and will still get the space
on the king side next
i do not like the look of this well b4
c3 i've seen some of these variations
before
it's going to be a quick knight d2 to b3
and what this should indicate to roberto
is that he needs to play bishop c8
no roberto that's not what i was going
to say it's not supposed to indicate
you're putting all your pieces back on
their starting squares no
i mean he's doing it to play 87 but how
can you play with this little space
i'm telling you he needs a whole
different opening because
they say all pawns no hope i see just no
hope
just no hope it's all pawns for white
and b6 okay that's it
necessary move but after a takes b6 you
can't take with the a pawn
which is necessary if you want to play
c5 and c5 is not happening anytime soon
well now
with rp8 you're much more likely to see
it happen but still it just feels like
white is
well ahead it almost needs to happen i
mean i'm no expert on this stuff but
you know a new york man such as yourself
you're used to
you know living in these these tight uh
apartments you know
not a lot of space i mean roberto i
don't know if he's so used to that he
he really needs to to find places for
all his pieces here
because look at that bishop on f8 you
need to play knight c6 you got to get
bishop b7 you got to get castle but as
soon as you castle what's waiting for
you oh king side pawn storm
yeah it's not going to be fun either way
so he plays c5 just to
try to get some activity now i'd
probably take on d4
or b4 whichever you're going to take
back with the pawn i think in either
direction
and at least you have a target now you
can play a move like
pawn takes a5 knight c6 go after some of
the squares in the queen side
there is hope at long last yeah that
night maybe getting into
b4 is is going to threaten knight to c2
so that's already something if you play
a6 i think
knight before that knight on d7 can also
go to b6
after you push the pawn queen c1 played
by levy because he doesn't want to move
that a pawn at all and allow the moves
that i just mentioned
i'm playing bishop b4 and i am
developing i'm attacking a5 again i'm
pinning your knight
i'm also trying to castle and play f6
that's the theme
of this match so far as you know this
kind of position let me play f6
but roberto plays bishop
he wants to trade queens he wants to
play well
he wants to play knight b4 let's be
clear hitting that bishop and the bishop
on d8
covers the queen again it's just a it's
almost a tactic at this point oh
speaking of tactics
no no it doesn't work no i was thinking
knight takes e5 like
yeah just take with the queen oh my gosh
yeah that looks pretty exciting this
also looks good though
yeah no i i like knight before but yeah
it's some sort of sack
on e5 and just sort of just take it back
um was possible but hey
knight before queen trade and you know
not even gonna
rag on roberto for this one looks like a
great move as well this looks great
it's true because after queen c7 knight
takes d3 with check
throw in the intermezzo then recapture
the queen then your bishop comes to a6
oh my gosh queen b1 there has to be
like five one not too special but
it's just a move it's nothing nothing
crazy what do you mean it's just a move
that's like the opposite of that's not a
move by candy that's a move
doesn't win anything but you get some
nice uh style points from the judges
yes i would definitely be giving you a
10 even if it doesn't deserve it so what
actually does this work
yeah bishop a6 that way if the bishop
takes knight c2 check you don't just
recapture
you throw in that check you win the
queen and that spells
trouble for levy here yep this is a
uh deadly move uh roberto we we know
he's
a solid solid player but we always
mention when it comes to the tactics
he can hang it's just he doesn't prefer
those positions but hey
this position required tactics to go
forward knight c2
levy knows that he's losing his queen
here but he sort of didn't have an
option bishop a6 so strong he was going
to win something
right so rook takes b1 he'll take back
with a rook
probably take on e3 for roberto maybe
there's knight takes e5 coming next or
bishop g5
check all that looks pretty good so
unfortunately for levy this is really
out of hand and after how many moves was
it
10 moves i thought white was just
cruising
and then that's the downside of having
your king in the center
and the pawn breaks happen and your
king's caught in the
fire here and black skiing is in the
center too but it's just one material
g5 bishop g5 is the end of the game
i'm not sure if he notices the move
because he's not playing it
wow totally missed it too solid bishop
b6
closes the b file and
i guess bishop takes d4 check is a good
move too right
well if you're playing bishop v6 uh i
feel like you're not looking at bishop
d4 check but
uh you're right yeah that that move
looks great as well you might be just go
king d8 i feel like that's the most
roberto move
yes king d8 is probably what's going to
be played here and
you just get out of the pin you're up
material so it should still be good
and six seconds for levi i didn't even
see that yeah he's
he's consistently in these uh these
situations f6 played he's trying to
try to drum up something
and roberto thinking which means he
might even play f takes e5 and
keep taking pawns yeah i think that's
wrong nothing wrong with king takes d7
though nope
no he's spoiled for choice right now
can't complain knight b3
looking for knight b5 but queen a3 is
going to make sure that knight stays
pinned
and hey another trade i'm up a lot of
material
and is what roberto is saying right now
yeah e5
taking advantage of the pins everywhere
looks pretty good just watch out for g5
if white can play g5 and spring free
that past pawn
that's the only counter play but not
when the queen's coming into g3
scooping up g4 scooping up h5
too much stuff watch out for the knight
fork on e5 that would be tragic
that would be one way to go out um f6
pawn can be taken
knight c5 he's getting in there with
some uh some tricky knights but
i mean every pawn in the position can be
taken right now
and rook g1 played takes on c5 and
what e5 now just trying to dislodge that
knight from c5
i guess he accomplished it with the
check and how many extra pawns does
black have
well after you take on h5 that's a clean
four
gotcha and that this should be easy but
watch out for knight forks they're
always tricky
in an 85 rip d7 by the way that's
that's closing in on checkmate oh how do
you
wait he's lucky as queenie one
there's no other way to stop it yeah you
have to play queen e1 just give a bunch
of checks
and you need to take the d4 pawn so i
think if you queenie three two 23
yeah uh he needed queen okay wait a
minute now the king just shuffles
yeah you gotta go back like queen c8
wait a second
queen e4 queen before you take a d4
check he's missing it
he's totally missing the plot here yeah
you queen f2
you can't go to f3 this isn't a huge
choke
okay it's gonna be a three time or
something he has it now he has queenie
for check of king d3 it's a queen e3
check
and he's gonna take on d4 wow that was
close levy putting up stubborn defense
wow it's not even over of course but
uh out of out of the woods out to queen
c5 oh
no he just wants to push that pawn i
guess and now he's going to take
one i mean roberto is making
himself work overtime at
his own company that's the way it feels
right now robert
yes and the game was just ended there
because we're
going to go to a break but aman what a
game that was where
roberto had the upper hand from the
opening he was had a winning advantage
and what do you make of the changes that
happened after the first segment
now that we see them playing slightly
different variations in their openings
who needs to change now um well i think
that those
cairo cons like they seem to somehow
work out for roberto so
he's going to keep going for them but if
you're levy i wouldn't shy away from
them
almost every single position has been
good minimum playable
some of them just totally winning so do
not shy away from those if you're levy
however
i think from the flip side uh levy
seriously needs to look at the game that
we saw where the pawn got to f3
uh and it was just a positional
masterpiece so i'm quite honest
by roberto so if i'm levy i'm taking a
look at that opening i believe it was
the queen's gambit accepted and i'm
making sure that position
never happens again yeah with few
exceptions it feels like the player with
the opening advantage is the player that
loses the game and
that last one clearly an example of that
where levy had the perfect
position of the opening all the space
control and then roberto was able to
break through so we're gonna take a
break
when we return we'll continue this three
plus one segment of this i'm not gm
speeches championship match
brought to you by chess.com we see the
players getting mentally set
for their next series of games levy he's
back there he's out in the distance
trying to gather himself roberto
i don't even know what he's doing but
he's feeling himself quite literally
ahmad what to make of this man dude
every time i see roberto's camera he
stresses me out he just
it just looks like he's stressed for no
reason and it shows in his gameplay that
when when the time's ticking down he's
he's missing a few key tactics now
in the last game it didn't actually cost
him the game or
maybe a half point but uh that is the
type of stress
and and the nerves that he needs to keep
in check going forward because
you cannot be missing such important
tactics to close out games especially
when
the other end of the board you got levy
rosman who is finding them when it comes
down to it
yeah i hope during the break for his
sake he ate a protein bar and did some
puzzle rush because the tactics have
been in
levy's favor he's been super sharp in
those critical moments
and we do see another queen's gambit
accepted but instead of these bishop b5
lines pinning the knight on c6 levy
plays a6 and it's roberto to think so
good adjustment
by levy during that break and now for
roberto you cannot spend
half a minute you need to just go and he
finally does castle
yep and we have seen um you know similar
line before but roberto
uh shying away from e4 it looks like e4
early on was one of the reasons that we
saw that
bishop b4 pin and he's actually totally
changed
uh the line before levy could change it
himself so the interesting strategy
maybe he's thinking
okay going into the break levy's gonna
take a look at that line because i i had
a crushing game last time
so i'm going to take a look at a
different line so i stay ahead of him
and i'm always prepared and i can't tell
who is bluffing whom because levy
playing very quickly and then puts queen
e8 which
you don't play unless you prepared it
because queen e7 looked so much more
natural
i guess the points of d5 instead of d
take c5 the knight would have the e7
square to jump around to so
uh levy well prepared here roberto not
afraid and look at this diagonal kha
play that move
fill the diagonal
we need to see this for you know the the
ultimate scrabble word basically
queen takes e2 and uh interesting
position
knight knight d4 rather kept the
pieces on the board rookie one rook d1
the next couple moves probably won't
surprise you
i like roberto's position especially
when i see
knight f5 lingering taking on d6 and
that bishop on b2
is gonna be a monster it really is
although black doesn't have any true
weaknesses in the position there are
some tactical opportunities for roberto
the bishop on b2 is very strong
i just don't know where to apply
pressure on you get the knight to f5 the
bishop comes to e5 for example and says
now what and that's the hard thing to
figure out
for both sides honestly because levy
sees the knight f5 coming
does he preempt it with bishop e5 he
chooses that move
and is that he does knight f3 to kick
the bishop out so
it's hard to figure out all the moves at
this point
yeah and bishop's just gonna go back now
we could see this knight move but
careful knight a4
can actually just be taken with the
queen right sometimes just easy to
forget
when a piece is just sitting for many
many moves on a square
that is actually really unnatural uh not
where it usually is
you start to get lulled in this false
sense of security like oh yeah it's just
queen on d8 just like usual but
no not the case at all and levy trades
off the knights the bishop on b2
is thrilled to see that knight get out
the way and the g7 pawn that's what you
would like to team up on you just can't
get there so quickly
rook d4 comes to mind and then what i
still am not sure
how white's advantage goes from
aesthetic to actually something concrete
100 the knight on g6 um probably not the
most well-placed piece
knight e5 uh timely 95 would be good for
levy to
uh to get in the position i can
definitely see if
if we just go oh and knight f4 going
tactical here i'm not sure if this
is actually good or not if queen f1
though we see his idea
he wants knight takes h3 and queen takes
on f3 but i see the eval bar
going sky high and queen c4 is the
response after knight takes h3 check
he'll go king f1 just slide the king
over
say i'm safe over here and i guess their
ideas with rook g4 for white
there are ideas it must be rook d5 could
be considered
yeah rookie but basically if you can
chase the queen away from this
knight then you win on the spot so rook
d5 looks
looks winning for that reason alone that
there's no queen h5
there's no queen g4 and queen e4 you
just trade the queens and then go there
rook h4 played instead i think rook d5
was the one but rook h4 uh leaves
options for for levy all of a sudden
maybe knight g5
i guess knight g5 will take in his rook
g4 at the end at least that's his
intention but maybe black doesn't have
to take
back on g5 there could be some tactics
with the rook on d1
not being defended and i see the eval
bar is in black's favor so
there's clearly something here even if
it's not immediately obvious
imagine knight g5 knight takes g5 bishop
g3 right
oh my gosh that's it that's what it
looks like yeah that's it
hitting the rook threading mate and
rook takes d8 back because you're
hitting the rook on d1 and the rook
comes and gets and fall down there that
that is a shot and if you go rook
d5 for white there's knight takes f3
probably because knight d2 check
would be a fork at the end yep
takes and i think you just go bishop to
bishop to g3 here i'm trying to see if
there's another way to do the same
tactic but yeah other than queen takes
g5
which queen takes g5 doesn't lose on the
spot
certainly not the move you're supposed
to play no your bishop g3 move
is played levy finds it and roberto
didn't even see it look at his face
did you see that he lurched backwards
whoa
where did that come from i am not seeing
the tactics today
no it's it's uh the levy levy rosman
tactic show
for sure he is spotting everything but
most importantly
you know he might miss a tactic or two
in this match but i feel like when he's
needed to see a tactic he's found it he
certainly has and for
for roberto here he just can't believe
it how could i miss that
i'm such a strong player and he's not
saying in a bragging wage and his head
like what's wrong with me today i'm not
seeing anything
and for levy it's like all right i got
this i may be down one point but i'm
about to get that point back
and even though i'm lower on the clock
that's more than enough time to win this
one
bishop takes f2 um is available
if uh if needed
and so what's the material account it's
an oh a checkmate okay
who cares what the material is that is
made and that's gonna be
game over levy evens the match again i
mean we have not seen
have we even seen a two game lead
because we certainly haven't seen more
than that i feel like as soon as one of
these guys wins it's immediately
uh you throw thrown back in the other
guy's court we have not seen a two-game
lead this has been level the whole way
through
one player leads the next player evens
it up
and here you see queen eight four on
move two
and what a strange opening we have
already the knight on d4
feels safe for the time being and
it kind of is a sicilian allopin with
colors reversed
exactly and queen a5 for black is kind
of a
tricky sideline against the alpine when
white plays c3 so
um basically levy is saying hey i'll do
the exact same thing but
i got an extra move here i'm playing
with the white pieces so
makes sense and actually it's going to
end up looking like a c4
e5 opening a pretty standard english
position we might get
maybe something like just g3 bishop g2
and
castle for white here and we see the
start of that g3
bishop g2 next as you point out and for
black you can play knight d7 knight c5
to kick the queen and protect e4
but as is typical when you push your
pawn that far in the opening it could be
overextended and e4 could fall
yeah 100 this this pawn needs to be
supported by d5 you guys might all be
wondering what's
the point of queen a4 like why do we
even put that there well it's so that
after something like bishop g2
d5 couldn't be played with the queen on
a4 before 97 because of a pin so
the queen a4 even though it was played
on move 2 it was
already thinking ahead to this type of
position where
e5 is harder to play to support that
extended pawn in the middle
and after queen e7 i'm already looking
at queen c2 to attack that pawn another
time
he plays d3 which is a pawn
sacrifice right he takes d3 you can't
take back he'll probably just
castle and say let's open this center up
with your king on e8
uh-huh 100 knight c5 played and i think
you just go back to d1 here
and then castle again after pawn takes
pawn right definitely don't go back to
c2 that would have been a big play
yeah queen c2 you could just take with
the knight on d3 actually
we see castle uh it's going to be knight
captures on e2 followed by
you're gonna see rookie one very very
quickly and it's gonna be
all about the compensation here for levy
rosman which knight would you take with
i would have said take with the other
knight to maintain knight f5 tricks but
hard to say for sure and there was also
knight takes c6 tricks as well so i did
not like this knight capturing
i also don't like the response bishop e6
because i played knight d4 right back
hitting your bishop
and hitting the c6 pawn but b4 it is and
that that's a good move as well
yeah because b5 yeah e5 is fantastic
look how strong that bishop is
do we care that black is up upon here no
he can't even develop the bishop
the interesting thing about b5 is it
immediately
clarifies that there's no chance for
black to castle queenside that might be
something you consider with your bishop
on f8 unable to play kingside castle
but isn't roberto just completely uh
toast here
yes he's in huge trouble this is a
tactical nightmare for roberto
and levy with the smart opening choice
getting roberto uncomfortable and
look at the position here down a pawn is
levy but
up three moves in development castles
rook coming to e1 the bishop on f8 can't
get out
95 is a good choice all things
considered but i think f4
just kicks that knight out of the center
rook can come to e1 the c6 pawn is
hanging
white can play f4 to f5 it's in trouble
yeah f4 is a strong strong move next
i mean you could consider knight takes
e6 but i think he's just
okay he goes knight tc6 yeah followed by
f4 knight takes c4
queen a4 check and it's funny the queen
returns to that
move number two queen a4 check and this
time it would win a piece and win the
game
and here i think bishop h3 looks really
strong just putting pressure on the
e-cig fund how could you complain about
queen to a4 but now black is knight d4
which is very important it defends e6
and offers a queen train white does not
want to trade queens here
so maybe queen a4 was a slight
inaccuracy i i
think so i think so i think in the
previous position knight d5
looked completely crushing um utilizing
the pin
even here i'm thinking of knight d5 but
knight to d4
is a way to meet that which is kind of
annoying so 94
as you mentioned this is a big resource
for roberto and it might keep him i
don't think he's gonna
you know give him a better position or
anything crazy like that levy is still
in control
but he continues the game robert well in
control by the evaluation but by the
players feelings
maybe not because well he takes on c6
that's actually
probably still a good move but i feel
like roberto has to be happier
about the situation than levy who was
like i'm about to go crush you and
checkmate you and now it's like oh wait
i gotta figure out tactically
am i even still better here right and
i'm actually surprised roberto didn't
play queen takes c6
and then rook takes e6 king f7 hey
doesn't that guarantee a queen trade
yes and well queen e6 queen c6 check
king f7
your king is safe the bishop comes to e7
c4 is hanging queen e1 check
is a thread black is the one with a
safer king
yeah how did that happen this is a big
throw
from uh what it was a great great
opening position bishop d2
looks like a move to play but hey c4 is
hanging
and we've been talking about how this
position is turning around this is not
good
for uh for levy and that king on f7
is extremely safe there's like one check
available to white and as soon as you
like queen check i go bishop e7 you help
me develop thank you very much and
queenie one queen takes c4 after queen
c4 this queen d4 checks with bishop d2
not even that appealing if the bishop
moves elsewhere queen e3 check
looks scary so i think queen takes c4
right now
need to play that move if you're a
little slow with gp7 i think there's
other moves like knight d5 and rookie
one to contend with not a fan of so
take that pawn while you can this is an
important moment you're threatening
queen g4 winning a piece
and he plays bishop e7 like this is a
roberto thing
he moves the safe choice solid yeah too
solid though he can take on c4 now and
he probably has to
but i think that he should have taken
first yeah i think white
should have maybe played knight d5
instead of rookie one
because six seconds left he he has to
have
you know a tactic here otherwise roberto
is gonna play rookie e8 as he does
defend defend defend and i think he's
okay now
right his king goes to f8 he's safe f5
just trying to hope for some bishop f4
or something to attack with
but with the queen on d3 hitting f5
hitting d2 and now even
d5 for black d4 to follow it's looking
too good
yeah oh i was gonna say there might be
it might have been some ideas with rook
f2 there
some sort of knight d5 but bishop f4
trying to get something going with rook
takes e7
and a queen trade proposed that just
cannot be accepted by levy
and here come the pawns d4 queen d5
mm-hmm okay oh i was gonna say queen f3
but there's a rook in the way
so yeah unfortunately it's just not
gonna work no
yeah queen h1 or queen f3 h1 gets a
queen trade so obviously h1
yes there we go designation so that is a
huge disappointment for levy
because he was playing such a good game
out of the opening and yet roberto
he hung in there and was able to not
just survive but win
and this is why um i think this might be
an important turning point
not only is the three plus one portion
getting closer being over
but i feel like the players have been
trading win for win win for win
and with the white pieces in this
opening we've often seen roberto
get the win so it's almost like in
tennis i feel like maybe he's broken
serve
and if he wins another game now that
two-game lead is gonna be harder to come
back from and it'll be the first time
that we've had it in this match
that's right you do not want to face a
two-game deficit
another player does and i've seen people
saying and it's true that
levy has shown some real might in the
previous matches in the bullet portion
but unfortunately for levy
he's facing probably the best other
bullet player in the whole competition
in roberto molina who's 2 800 plus in
that time control so
there's going to be no advantage in that
segment which means that you need to
go into it without a deficit you want to
win this game obviously
and there are only six and a half
minutes remaining this could potentially
be our final game
or very likely we'll have one more after
this right
and the the other problem is that um
if you're roberto you've got to focus up
in this game the last time we saw an
opening like this
near the end of the segment it was
actually a very convincing crush
by uh by levy with the black pieces if
we remember so
uh g4 and what about these dark squares
here i'm concerned after knight g6 for
roberto's position
if he were another player i would say
he's gonna play h4 sacrifice that castle
queen
side and just open up the position but
he's
not he's you know himself he's gonna
play the more solid approach
unfortunately for him levy's castle
levy's striking
and it looks really nice for levy at
this point uh yeah i think he missed the
pawn though
uh queen takes g5 instead of rookie
eight looks uh
pretty game over i know you don't like
to take pawns uh in front of your king
but
i don't see any way that that gets
exploited here by white although this
still looks
very promising for levy that knight
trying to come into b3
now e takes f4 probably throw in knight
b3
there um as a consideration but i
i think this is solid and good and no
need to go for
anything unnecessarily complicated the
only hope that i would say white has is
if that knight could just move like a
bishop for one second and go to d4
then you'd be like okay that nice game
to c6 i have some counter play here
but the e4 pawn is weak the dark squares
under black's control
the king obviously safer for black maybe
some kind of f6 move in the near future
i really like levy's position i have to
ask like what what's rook a to c8 i
really don't get that move um
not sure if he wants to play c6 or c5 i
feel like those moves are not really
necessary but
yeah okay he just plays rook c8d and i
wonder if it was honestly a mouse slip
i think it was a mistake i think he
wanted to push his c pawn
and he then realized well the bishop one
g4 can't do that
and roberto got a trade that he really
wanted to have
because now that knight isn't going to
harass
white's position and even though i still
like black's position i think that white
has good chances
with the light square control i'm
looking at that c6 square i'm looking at
a queen c6 in the future
because i know how much roberto wants to
trade queens and then i look at the king
side and say how do you go checkmate
white
because you do want to go for the attack
knight look at this move knight a2
he's going knight before and probably
knight c6 immediately
um and i was going to say very surprised
by that move not only is there bishop d4
which he potentially overlooked but even
just taking that pawn and taking back
i'm not once again not convinced by the
two rooks over here i think he should
just take it on g5
and he brings his work back to d1 with
tempo against the bishop
knight before a very serious threat okay
we had this position
right yeah and he went rook g1 last time
now he takes on h6
exactly but it's time for the rook lift
rook descent oh i
didn't like that capture i think the
rook left immediately it was the way to
go
who cares about the number of pawns
there just go for the king yeah
or you could even be as crazy as to
consider something like a5
that hardly makes sense but it would
have stopped night before i think knight
b4 is super super strong
however it might cause levy to lift the
rook like
if he wasn't thinking of it before he
might be like oh night
night there i got to do something about
this fork what wait a minute rook d6
looks decent
and he brings the queen in which isn't
the piece you want to see there
and now i'm thinking hey can i just move
my rook back to g1 my king out of the
way and
use the attack and the open lines for my
pieces rather than being attacked
and he plays rook d2 the ultra solid and
i think smart in this instance
moved by roberto protecting b2 and now
his king ducks out the way
he has g2 covered g1 covered the only
place for
black is rook g8 rook g3 but at some
point rebecca could take on e5 the c7
pawns under attack
there are some problems for levy to
figure out yeah i'm still thinking that
rook uh g8 makes some sense um
knight takes e5 queen c7 queen c3
sorry i i overlooked that queen trade
option
of course we did queen c3 i mean
honestly a good move
but it was not expected at this point in
time and well is he just going to run
his king over
king he won king d1 keep going i was
thinking rook f2 king e2
oh that's probably better just to cover
f3 and then he'll consider
queen takes c7 again and levy's sitting
and thinking
he actually might have to move c6 here
because and he plays it because rook d1
check is deadly if you take on c6 your
rook on h1 can't be defended
so this was an oversight by roberto
being
too solid again offering a queen trade
then bringing in his rook to the defense
not seeing some of levy's counter
chances there was e5
check there but then the rook would
slide over to g6 which is why
that wasn't a miss tactic or anything
like that king h8
yeah he's going to check again on c3 and
what he wants is not what levy's going
to give him he won't probably wanted
that perpetual check
oh he would have loved that and f6 is a
double-edged
move on one hand you stop the checks
your rook can come into g3 and things of
that nature
but look at black's king pretty exposed
the rook on d6 needs to stay put the f6
pawn is
hanging the rook on g8 probably needs to
stay put because there was queen c8 but
now after
queen f5 of course queen d3 was played
and i love queen f5 covering c8 also
sneaky threatening queen to b1
which was winning the game so queen f5
super resourceful by levy
we see queen e5 here how about another
queen trade
uh rookie he's gonna get it there's no
choice you can trade queens but have a
queen e5 rookie five
down goes the d5 pawn and black will be
up one with those double f pawns for
black not sure it's enough to
claim it oh that's a great move throwing
rook g6 in or rook g4
well done by both players in this game
yeah and i think
uh you know might just see brook be two
or something like that
look f5 what the 4k the rook's trapped
if you take
wow what a what an idea that was
fantastic by levy
yeah and roberto's holding his head he's
not comfortable being down upon here
because he could just be lost
yep yep i think there's a good chance
that levy wins this game
we see the low time but i have to say in
a rook end game is the best chance
uh for for levy the best position you'd
want to be down on time in
and he roberto allowed levy to play hr i
think roberto should have done that
himself
but he's just trying to hold steady here
so you can't go after my pawns and if
you do my rook
gets to attack the pawns you're
neglecting and here comes the rook to c1
levy two seconds now three rook c6 rook
a6 or b6 just bring your rook behind
black's pawns
that's the way to go so levi still has
great chances to win here but i think he
made a blunder earlier he had the rook
on c2 he could have taken on b2
and white would take on f4 didn't go for
that and
yeah i think he's completely messed it
up i hate to be this guy but this is a
position where black can lose
because now white has the clear pass
pawn and black has three seconds left
yep
and here you're gonna get the king e4
you can try there's rook c4 but
okay so rook b8 push the b pawn it's
uh oh b5 yeah b b5 might just win
c4 yeah look at this the rook can't get
to b3 and that's important because
yep b7 and rook this uh
g8 rather is gonna be game over you
can't get the rook behind the pawn
and put your king there so he's gonna
try to queen his spawn but to no avail
and this is a big turning point in the
match because levy had he
converted this he would be even heading
into bullet and it's still on over
roberto has to finish this off but i
think he's capable of doing so although
he went back to where he came from
that's not the best way
to convert this and for rook g5 what i
think he wants queen
f8 to take the pawn and if okay i guess
you couldn't take on
h4 there but there's some chances to
hold this for levy for sure
queen d4 looks really strong okay so the
king's just going all over the place
and kiki's six now the king's up there
then yeah yeah this is done
and g6 g6 is a good way to do it trade
well not trade but lose
material there and once again roberto
doesn't get the
conversion in the cleanest way possible
but you know what the end of the day
he did get the conversion and we talked
about how
we could see another game but that game
was so long
robert it took so much time but that was
actually the final game in the portion
so you know what say that it was bad
conversion but maybe that's just big
brain he just wasted
all the the clock time remaining in the
three minute portion and he's taking the
matches first two-game lead
into the break it must be heartbreaking
for levy at this point he still has
plenty of opportunity there's 25 minutes
of bullet chest ahead
but he was on the verge of evening this
match back up
and now you look at the scoreboard
you're down two you see roberto's bullet
rating
that doesn't feel too good but if
anybody can make a comeback in bullet it
is levy rosman he still has a chance
and so i think we should take this break
because when we return we'll get into
that final time segment
and all the action remains ahead you
will not want to miss it stay tuned
and this bullet portion is for all the
marbles and
that trophy that you see on screen this
is the final you i don't think they're
getting a physical trophy so maybe
they'll have to get an nft of that thing
there
but amman it is the grand final here we
have roberto molina we have
levy rosman these two are duking it out
and all that remains
is some bullet chest roberto up two
points
can levy get this done well first of all
um the the match so far has been highly
entertaining and also
very very close i don't think we've
really had a closer match between
uh two heavyweights in this tournament
however we saw the first
sort of serve break as i indicated uh
two-point lead for roberto
this match was pretty much destined to
go into the bullet tied up
but once again levy's being put in that
situation that he often finds himself in
where he has to make a comeback in the
bullet now you might be saying well
he's done that almost every single match
in the tournament thus far i'm with you
i agree
however he hasn't played anyone as high
rated or as
dangerous and bullet as roberto molina
say what you want about his chest
solid style but in bullet chest
sometimes that solid
quick chest style is very very effective
and here we go we have that english
which is like a reverse sassone alpine
and roberto puts the bishop on c5 this
time going right after the night so he
clearly looked at something
and figured out this is a better way to
go look at that queen a4 mod that's
pretty awkward
yeah it can't really get back into the
position it's kind of
you play queen a4 well now you're you're
stranded out there and will we see like
g3 and no i was wondering if we would
see a pawn sacrifice
he plays a little bit more normally
captures back and it might get castled
on the queen side yeah he does castle
queen side but
black is ready to attack d5 says let's
open that side of the board up
a6 b5 comes to mind knight b to d7 and
just bringing that knight out to c5 or
something like that i feel like
white down 20 seconds in in this
position i don't know i'm not really
feeling it
yep i agree with you g3 is looking to
maybe get that bishop to g2
knight g4 pressuring that bishop on e3
he's not so comfortable
instead live he's saying hey take that i
want your d-pawn
and that d-pawn on the direct three
times bishop e6 would be the way to
defend but then the knight comes into d4
to attack it
so he takes on c4 the queen is back in
the game at long last
and now there's an e3 weakness but two
pawns in the center for white so
essential control potential problems
with pawns though
yeah and two bishops as well for roberto
which is why i think the engine is
comfortable with black's position but um
opposite side castling
this is going to be a tactical game no
matter what
and roberto up 15 seconds right now
pawn to a4 you could think about pawn a3
but then white pushes the pawn to b3 to
keep that
queen side closed so i think both sides
are doing a very good
job and look at levy go time to break
open the position bishop 24 queen h5
next
there could be an attack on the h7 pawn
yeah and remember roberto is
not developed yet that bishop isn't out
the the f8 rook doesn't have the support
of its uh
his counterpart on uh a8 to just swing
over oh there's
he needs to catch up in development here
levy is sticking it to the king
before black is fully mobilized and levy
was ready
he put h4 instantly he said let's go
let's play h5 soon
he takes an f8 to distract the queen
from the e7 square now plays h5 and
ooh g5 this is so risky for black
yeah and immediately h6 now if that
pawn is taken there's rook h1 i'm
surprised we're not seeing bishop f5
from roberto
he takes g3 he takes the other pawn and
then bishop can go to f4 or to h4 to
block the rook and he goes to f4 here
and now the bishop will go to h3 with
tempo bishop f5 your idea is still a
possibility
and this could be a problem for white
because those pawns might drop
and i like the move bishop h3 just
tickling the rook
causing it to move off the f-file i
think roberto has played a fantastic
game
he now has six seconds we finally get to
see roberto and his bullet skills with
low time on the clock
and he wants to play a3 to soften the c3
square but he goes rookie a first
the knight is pinned in attack twice
this is wild four seconds you got to
move i don't even know what the move
should be but
he takes an e5 and just keeps taking
queen h2 tricky move queen e7 guarding
it
the knight moves so you can take on c2
and there's also rook e1 a huge move
coming up next
i think you just oh that's king g8 but
now number six
native check he missed knight f6 oh and
he
now it's just a piece you can take it go
wait he's still moving the king
oh my gosh he's running with the king
and he takes an eight second
check questions he made with one point
six seconds left he barely got that move
off
he needs to move he loses time oh he
loses on time whoa
and just when he went ahead material he
loses on the clock and
levy is right back in this it is one
point separating these two players
and what a match has been what a match
it will remain and there could be tie
breaks we're looking at a situation
this close we could end up in the tie
break scenario
yeah we'll we'll discuss that when it
becomes more of a possibility and when
the time in the one plus one section
gets lower and lower but for now uh the
levy fans
can at least tell themselves look we are
still in this that was an insane
win and he needed that robert uh to have
a chance in this match that would have
been three games
ahead for roberto he did need that he
was able to
win it and now is a position that's
closed in the center this pawn e4
we've talked about in previous games
where that pawn effort could be over
extended to weakness roberto maneuvers
knight from f3 to d2 to c4
and bishop back to f1 make sure there's
no sacrifice in the h3 square
i'd like roberto's position here it's
just not so easy
wow to break through when he plays f4
yeah kind of understandable f4 you just
don't like those positions where
the pawn on e4 has so much space that
black gets a free hand to attack
i caught me off guard though i have to
be honest when he plays b5 trying to
open the queen side
while levy's aiming at the king side so
playing on opposite flanks
interesting scenario right now bishop e4
normally you see a bishop for a night
trade dude bishops you take that but
he's saying look i can take that bishop
anytime it's not going anywhere it can't
be it can't move anywhere
so now i might take when the knight
can't capture back for example
i might take him like there's knight b1
he looks like bishop a3 and bishop a3 it
is after f5 walks right into it
i actually don't think this is that bad
for levi yes he's losing material
but he's gaining an attack yeah i agree
knight b1 is such a telegraphed move
levy almost
didn't expect it to be so obvious queen
g5 you mentioned that attack coming in
is it going to be f4 i feel like we have
to do something here
i would be looking right for f4 because
knight is four first don't touch that g
pawn then the f3 square is black for the
taking
and look at the clock by the way roberto
45 seconds how is he moving so quickly
this is like you know we've always
talked about how good levy is in time
scrambles but it feels like
levy's really good in those time
scribbles uh in blitz but now that it's
bullet
watch out for roberto and watch out for
the back rank because rook takes f4 is
met by rook ca check and your king
is in trouble here rook takes e4 should
be good enough the bishop
uh queen trade uh queen trade and take
on e2 thank you very much and the knight
of five check what was that
uh that was just a lack of confidence
because bishop c4
brook takes e4 and bishop c4 in the
previous position was all he needed
uh instead he's now got this position
which should be a draw but
i mean yeah they are going to draw what
it looks like but another example
of roberto playing too solidly when he
could have played for more he was up
material
and he just trades queens off and he's
plenty of time he's 39 seconds
when they agreed on a draw there which
means that he could have spent 20
seconds in that moment
trying to find a better move yep that's
a that's a good point the reason that
these guys are agreeing to a draw
is because they're both such strong
players and neither one of them feels
like they have a big advantage in this
format it's just
evenly matched here so no one wants to
waste time because you know what robert
they might need it later
they really might you don't know who's
going to be ahead when there's one game
remaining so they're both players
looking
for their chances here look at this g4
rook g1
speaking of telegraphed ideas going for
the king side here
but roberto says so what you can't
attack me with a lone rook
yeah what about taking on f5 followed by
knight d4 it's that bishop sort of has
to choose this diagonal bishop to g6
there's knight e6
and he plays d3 which he's played pretty
much every game in this line
i don't really like it with the king
sitting on e1 and no ability to castle
so i think roberto has
a big advantage and he's looked nervous
but right now he's stressing to impress
and
i think this is a good opportunity for
him this this could be a crush for
roberto knight takes f2 prevents
castling and bishop h4
is the other dangerous move that's about
to arrive in the position this looks
awful it looks really really bad knight
takes f2 bishop h6 could be a potential
idea
probably doesn't work out bishop h4
first hitting f2 with a
third piece and that's the hammer
because f2 is captured with check once
the bishop lands there
now this is no good for levy and he's
down 25 seconds
and this is where the queen on a4 is
like what like look at that thing
how are you going to play h3 g4 and
attack the king when your queen is on
a4 and can't join the attack for like
four or five moves
and roberto yeah he reacted like
he made a mistake so he didn't like what
he did but i like what he's doing the
queen's
oh i just say isn't that a free piece
the queen of a4
is making itself useful by defending the
bishop and it's important note that
bishop on f2
needs to stay put to defend the queen
otherwise bishop e6 check would pick up
the queen instead of just trade it
maybe knight takes c5 then for that
exact reason just
him into that i think there might be a
queen h1 move to reckon with but
that was what i would be thinking of as
a cheapo i i like the idea
and he plays knight a6 protecting the c5
pawn
and after queens for king h8 94
knight before oh that's so problematic
because your king is
forced back to the first rank and here
comes another piece for black into the
attack
oh no let me try the c5 pawn is covered
yeah it's trapped
oh gosh now the bishop hangs in g4 i've
resigned i'm leaving
resigning immediately next game look at
this we've never seen
anyone do this to levy like 30 seconds
he's up queen d7 that's a free queen
he did i well he shook his head so i'm i
think he did it on purpose just to hope
for some kind of mistake and
hang in the queen but that was a
situation where roberto rolled him over
that
cannot be repeated no i mean but we're
seeing even in the games where levy does
win
like the time from roberto i mean people
are just
only starting to tune in this is what
you know 2800 can
do in bullet he is so quick and even
though it might not reflect
uh his tactical ability in uh the slower
time controls
i say slower in the speedchest
championship talking about five-minute
chess but what we're seeing in bullet
here
is different beasts roberto is sharp
right now he is and there's still
over 15 minutes remaining so even if a
three game lead or it's cut to one here
both sides will have chances remaining i
like levy's position here
he is going for the queen side the king
side where there's an open g file is
being ignored and at some point i was
about to say the h2 pawn can be captured
he does it right away yeah it's funny
that h2 pawn poor guy
just getting sniped from c7 you might
think oh it's opening up lines to attack
but look at all the pieces they're all
on the other side
of the board there's no attack happening
no there certainly is not a rook c8
played
and we see a trade of ropes oh so
distracting the rook then the bishop one
c5 is under attack
and what i'm looking at for levy is can
i just play h5h4h3 and try to queen
uh i i think that's the plan because
even if it doesn't work
it is scary enough that i mean you you
in bullet chess
that's exactly what you do robert a nice
easy plan that you can nearly pre-move
and queen g1 is a big threat right now
that bishop on e1 doesn't have defender
so i i think you just take on c4 you
probably have to and then play h5 to
make sure you go queen g1 first yeah
whoa
he's thinking about queen g1 first i
don't know if it's right there might be
some fancy
move like i'm almost looking at queen d3
that type of move but
uh bishop's hanging with checks he goes
queen before guards it however what to
do here
i think h5 just push that pawn you can't
go rook h4 because rook d1 check
brings the rook here now you can i can't
push h4 because the queen's there ah
it's a little annoying
and it's still covering it however watch
out for a4 this is literally gonna be a
race
between the h and the a pawn and the
queen goes to f1 and go to d3 with check
and a4 would be too risky so queen q3
check now the f3 pawn
is vulnerable and a queen trade offered
it's typical to move yeah this is smart
that's a really good move the bishop
from e1 if you take that queen covers h4
bishop c3 we're just gonna see a3
nice and solid and i think i think this
position is great for roberto
although be careful because those light
squares over there on the queen side
knight c5 knight b3 check just keep a
lookout for that
anyways came to be one getting off the a
file where any sacrifice would have
landed with the check
so queen d3 that's really good that
queen that's a strong
strong move and you know what queen d5
is going to be played look at the time
once again he constantly has 30 seconds
against five
he's such a fast player although look at
that h pawn g5
h4 96 i would be really careful
if i'm roberto i want to push b4 b5 a4a5
get my queenstop pawns going
that feels slower well you talked about
b4 there it is knight goes to e6 as you
mentioned
g5 h4 all those moves coming in black's
position is shaping up here
yeah knight takes f3 and then push the h
pawn oh you gotta move
he does move h4 keep pushing him h3
rook d1 h3 h2 go all the way it's gonna
be two pawns on the queen side against
the rook
the g pawn doesn't help g5 was probably
too slow because now b6 a5 a6 you get
all those pawns going
and it's crazy how one tempo and chess
can
completely change the evaluation e6 b7 i
think rook c1
is also something to look out for and
that trade is not going to help as the h
pawn falls now
and just rook h6 and yeah that's game
over after e5
yeah d3 hope for rook takes up six no he
brings king back
smart guy brook d6 if he wants yep
and then a7 and then you can't take on
e5 okay i suppose e6 but now that we're
going to go so he has a chance to hold
this game
it's almost it's almost oh it's worse
oh wait a minute what okay everyone's
missing something here
the bar was going yeah
rookie eight though rookie eight oh good
call
easy to lose this in bullet great move
rook b3 he's trying to cut the king off
uh wait you didn't trade rooks you could
play the rooks that doesn't make any
sense he's going to lose this game now
because the king is cut off he could
have traded brooks that's a huge throw
the king is cut off and this is going to
be the standard lucina position
with tons of time to execute it that
throw and it's what you were saying that
the actual ability to play on is bad for
levy because it wastes time
and wow that's a big moment
and the pawn pushes the king comes up i
would just resign
man this is this is just terrible to
play on because you know it's losing and
you also know the other guy knows
how to convert it even rook a5 doesn't
even threaten mate here
right the rook on d2 covers the d8
square so we see resignation is a three
point lead for roberto now and
that's that's big that's huge still
almost 11 minutes plenty of time but
levy needs to win and he needs to win
now
yep that's that's exactly what it is he
has to win now he's going with the
london system in a must-win game
is it gonna be knight bd2 yes it is and
what does roberto have against
this opening is my question it's gonna
be e6 ultra solid
bishop d6 queen b6
of course i'm laughing because if
anyone's gonna trade queens it is
roberto but this can be annoying this b6
pawn
it's stuck there it's doubled and bishop
back to g3 so
it's not like white has any huge
advantage right now it's not the long
term potential
well i mean we're playing a london
system so you're definitely right that y
doesn't have
any huge advantage that's pretty much uh
in the rulebook when you play the
opening to start off bishop c7
going for trades he doesn't need to do
anything special here i think white
comfortable position but nothing nothing
crazy just yet
well e4 was a big mistake you can't
afford to have your center collapse in
this manner
and i think it's because of the match
score like levy just played e4 to break
things open i need to win the game
if he had been even on the scoreboard he
probably would have taken a little more
care
full pawn down there's going to be
knight d4 to follow you know the knight
can just reach
uh f6 i think he's going to go knight a4
yeah even though there's knight d5
here followed by knight c to e7 ultra
solid
strong he gives up the b6 pawn that
cannot be good
because white has this outside past pawn
now
there's there's hopes here for levy
rosman however those knights still look
dangerous to me
but uh look look at the uh look at the
game by levi here he's got chances
and bishop comes to e4 covering the c2
square hitting the knight in the center
and knight on a4 though that's the
problem i'm on if you play b4 rook eight
happens and the a3 pawn
falls next so you need to get that
knight back and it's just a struggle to
do so
yeah maybe g3 to take the f4 square but
hang on rook c4
stacks two pieces what about that
knighton a4 can we just attack it with
rook a8 where does it go
well now it's going to b6 and that
bishop on e4 is thrilled to be there
because the b7 pawns in trouble if
knight c6 b4 or b5 or
b4 a4 a5 things like that the knight is
not that stable
on c6 it goes to d5 i would be tempted
to capture it and then go after the
d-pawn this end game is much better for
white
it is but i kind of like the decision to
go for that rook end game because the
bishop on e4 was looking really really
strong
instead he's bringing the king and i
don't like b4 at all all of a sudden the
a pawn is
an easy target but if that pawn gets to
a5 that's a different story
and that d-pawn is well defended now the
b7 punt over protector so the rook on c7
can release into the position with rook
c3 or rook c2 or rook c4
even so i think that this is a good
decision by roberto he's using his clock
wisely and levy
you know he needs to get this game i'm
looking at eight minutes he doesn't have
to he can win the next two and have
enough time
for one more but he certainly can't
afford to lose this
it looks like it's going to be a long
game i mean if a6 happens
but the only person that has chances
here seems to be roberto but
um do you think robert that he is going
to take a quick draw here or he's going
to play it out for what could be
like up to a minute two minutes i'm
playing this out
i'm just shuffling my rook back and
forth i have 20 seconds
i can waste match clock and get this
down to seven
minutes maybe six and a half easily i
think
much more than that i think that you can
play
about you know 40 50 moves here
and that's 40 50 seconds a piece i think
you can take two three
seconds off the clock or sorry two three
minutes off the clock easily
well we see the checks and then now
we're back to thinking do i want to keep
giving checks no because rook to d1
and if i'm levy i probably would just
keep trying like king g5 king f4 and
back and forth but it's not easy to
accomplish all these things and you just
lost a work end game
so you need to be careful that you don't
make any kind of silly blunders
agreed and the king's up on g5 f6
check king has to go to h5 only move but
then you'll give a rook b7 check at the
end of the line so
that would not be advisable right and
here i think you could play f6 check if
you wanted to
i think roberto is just avoiding any
sort of danger
it might not be that dangerous but hey
he went for it there we go now now
something like rook c5
is going to hit that pawn and this is
this is not what levy wants
rook g1 cut that king off and this is
very very frustrating you could even
just lose this on the board or something
with rook g5
and bring the king in oh my gosh like
king e7
before check rookie for check was uh oh
oh no
i think you have to lose this pawn now
this is as bad as it could be
for levy he's not even playing king e5
he's like he's going the slow way
no and his pawns going down and it
should still be a hold
but it's very difficult with notes like
he's not taking it that's exactly he's
wasting more time
he's just going king d2 that's smart
super smart
oh no king of three we're gonna tries
mate uh oh
okay rook h4 saves the day for now but
rook takes a five
i would take the point
of meeting that and now rook g5 f5 f4
and we can see him lose by this okay he
he allowed the king to get through and
roberto knows he just messed that up
yep however it's not all about that
it's not all about the result robert
it's about taking match but look at
he did take about two to three minutes
off the clock and he can still go for
another
minute just wait until he pushes f5 this
is move 91
we're getting to 150 moves easily
easily i would i think this should go
even more than that
are we about to break some sec record
for longest game played
i hope so technically that pawn on f5
should stay there
for 49 moves right if we're maximizing
as black
obviously it's bullet you know nothing's
going to be perfect but i'm just saying
that's the
that's the idea although the issue here
is rook g8 check is coming in the king
to f4 so you might not have
too much of a choice you're still
playing this though
mark f1 you're bringing the king down to
h7
you could play rook g4 check i knew he
was going to do that because now he
can't lose and
if you can't blunder a rook and he can
just play this out for a while
yep this is at least another 20 seconds
this went from
seven and a half minutes to under five
yep there's g3 and he's gonna repeat all
those again and then he can let his 15
seconds run out as well
this is unbelievable
that might be three okay these three so
she probably shouldn't have played that
move but
let's just talk about the job he did
there he just took
so much time off like i was like three
or four minutes
you were correct once again partner and
roberto
he's inching closer and closer to the
title because there are four minutes and
20 seconds remaining
levy needs to win all the remaining
games so he needs to be able to win two
games
with two seconds remaining on the match
clock to start that final game
and right now with the white pieces i
have to say i prefer roberto's position
i'm taking a b8 by the way if i'm uh
roberto just simple simple chess trade
bishop for night
don't even worry about the position he's
just doubling rooks i mean i don't even
see
how levy really wins this position
either that's the tough part
well he pushes up on a b4 which is a
good plan for black if you take bishop
takes the rook only one would have been
lost he's opening up the queen side
and that's a bit scary for
white with his pawn a2 and okay well
he's doing this which might be a good
move honestly just
kind of out of desperation as well
mm-hmm
okay yeah you can release the e8 rook
the knight protects the bishop there
understandable
yeah this makes a lot of sense this is
kind of cool
i really like the whoa exchange sack by
roberto saying you're not getting that
b4 pawn i have a
bishop and two pawns for your rook and i
really like that yeah i'm not sure black
is better and the very least is going to
take a lot of time
to win a position like this if you can
that's the issue
um that i see is that um let's say levy
wins this game
there's i think the match is over
because it's currently a three game lead
um i think roberto's play in the last
game the game prior
just won him the match and i i might go
as far back and maybe as be as bold to
say that the final three-minute game
won robert to the match because that was
one where levy had it in the bag it
seemed
rebecca somehow survived that scary
opening and then levy
couldn't handle it and lost and so
roberto took a two-game lead
instead of it being an even match
heading to the bullet and this by the
way is
like roberto's better so this is not
even like
you know he's gonna lose this game lose
the next game and just win the match
no he's he's actually doing better in
this game he's up
he's got three pawns for that exchange i
mean this completely win it's a great
game by roberto honestly that exchange
stack
but on top of that i mean just the the
clock is running down the match clock is
running down
way too much and look at how compact his
position is the knight the rook the
bishop those pawns
on the center and on the queen side all
defended very nicely
so this is just vintage roberto and he's
winning this game that pawn is
very far advanced and just two precise
moves
and the game concludes exactly d5
just uh probably queen the pawn yeah
take on d5 some combo there
okay so the knight moved away i think
rook c7 rook c6 was possible there
dang knight m8 nobody likes knights in
the corner like that
oh i don't i don't like this move though
uh b5 needs to be played by
by white there we go and then king c4
bishop b4 as well or just b6 b7 that
looks
straightforward enough yeah he took on
f6
probably not needed but still good
yep he's uh the problem is black doesn't
have any pawns like he's got an h-pawn
we can't win without any pawns finally
he's going to start pushing it but i
think just v6
there he goes and rook b1 check does not
win the b6 pawn because
white can play bishop b2 blocking off
that rook
rook b7
there should be a checkmate somewhere
yes yeah you get that feeling i think
knight d7 knight v6
well 97 king d5 knight b6 king c6 be
careful
that's funny that's funny okay and he
saw it but that was a really good trick
by by levy there
oh rook take oh no not rock 67 because
there's bishop a3 to block the
the rook off that's been the saving
grace in many of these positions and you
can just
knight f6 and take that game so even if
you you know look at the match clock by
the way 25 seconds there was going to be
no chance of a comeback even if he loses
that game
but roberto now i mean he still looks
like this is a tied match and we're
going into armageddon
dude you just won i mean you're up four
games
do you think he knows that the match
clock's about to expire because it seems
like he doesn't
yeah it seems like he doesn't but even
if he doesn't what he should know
is that he's definitely won this match
because whether he knows that it's like
expired now officially and the match is
over he definitely looks
like this is match point you know
everything's on the line
tense position three seconds left and
his chair is shaking like there is
something going on he he is shaking you
could see it
vibrating here but roberto i mean all
the emotions will probably be let loose
when the match officially concludes but
he has been
so strong throughout this entire event
from the very first match against
celestia yes it was an odds match but he
showed his might there then he beat
lawrence trent and that was a real
battle lawrence gave molly could handle
then he beats lars oscar hogg by
sweeping the bullet
and finally in this last match against
levy rosman
there were wins traded off in the early
going then at the end of the three
minute portion he gets a two game lead
and in the bullet he proved why he's a 2
plus bullet player and for levy it's
been a great event as well but roberto
at this stage you can't say that he's
not
he certainly is a deserving champion
yeah and he's even gonna finish off with
a win here
you know you often see the last game you
know be a loss because they're already
so focused on
uh the match being over but the thing is
he doesn't know the match is over
so he's full full focus mode and he's
completely winning this game
yeah it's amazing he's paying attention
to nothing besides the moves the board
he's up a rook and a bishop and there's
a resignation and that's it
let's see does roberto finally breathe
he does
oh man oh my goodness i feel like it's
the first time that he's
he's taken a breath the entire match
and i think he's just falling asleep
because he he's
out of breath he's exhausted the wind is
gone and
okay for both players it's been an epic
tournament for levy of course this final
didn't go his way but
he was worthy of being in the finale
here and of course credit to roberto
molina approving
the the brazilian international master
who also is a streamer
he is trying to become a grand master
very powerful player
so mon any final thoughts before we go
to break and welcome the players for an
interview
well i i'll save my final thoughts for a
conversation with them because i'm sure
that
that both of these guys have a lot to
say after what was an insanely epic
match down to the wire robert the games
were very tactical
roberto was out of his element and he
was able to keep up with levy in
every time control and even demonstrate
uh
why he was actually the one to be feared
in the bullet portion and congrats to
him of course
absolutely everybody you will not want
to miss this post-match interview with
the champion and the runner-up so stay
tuned we'll be right back with roberto
and levy
and robert and i are still here but we
are joined with
both participants of today's epic final
match up
in the i am not a gm uh speech s
championship we have roberto
and levy both joining us uh roberto i'm
just gonna go to you
obviously congratulations on the match
but robert and i were
watching that final bullet game you had
already won the match but
you weren't not even not even breathing
it looked like you were locked in
still focused right to the end what do
you have to say about the match overall
and and your victory today
uh chess is always concentration and
i have some lucky to
some preparations lying
put in the games for example the queen's
get accept
[Music]
just this just uh
at the brazilian people
send me good energy to me it's it's
uh very important to play
my best yeah i mean
you definitely did play your best you
performed very well and
i mean levy you had a great event and
you were right in the thick of this
match
was it that final three minute game
after that when you had a great position
and then it slipped away
did you just feel like it was going to
be right there just match from there
uh yeah so um
that second to last uh blitz game where
i had the english the first time i
played this queen a4 and i had just a
great position and
um totally messed it up i mean
roberto defended like extremely well i
felt like that was the biggest
difference in the match every time i
felt good
he would just take my dreams away from
me um and then of course once i lost the
next game i'm sitting there like i gotta
win i gotta win i gotta win
and then i lose and i'm down two and i'm
like all right i still have a chance but
it's not the same because he's also very
good at bullet
i won that first game and i was hype and
then yeah he took uh he took my soul
after that and and then to add on to the
stress we just got a massive delivery
and our landlords are like
ringing on our doorbell incessantly and
banging on the door and i'm just sitting
here like
i'm giving this interview that's extra
stress but yeah gg's man you defended
really well i feel like both of us
played so nervous right yeah like
it was sure yeah we
we agree with that assessment i was
actually going to ask uh
you roberta what you felt in terms of
the nerves in this match because
uh it seemed like um there were a lot of
tactics that
you were missing in favor of more solid
and defensive moves now
do you think that's just more part of
your style or were you feeling that in
the finals
uh you were a little bit nervous coming
into this
uh in the beginning of the match i i was
totally nervous
for example in the first and the second
game
the first game i lost and the second
game i
uh the correct result is is
levi's wings but my phone's going
i don't know how they how they have
advanced
it but
but after this these never
start i
i begin focus more and and
try to to see the best
defenses some tech kiss but i think i
dropped some pieces
this is normal in blitz uh some good
positions i stake
that's okay right no of course it's
normal and levy
speaking of openings and on your end of
things your white piece against the
keracon
looks stellar every time you gained a
ton of space and
it looked very good for you is it weird
for you to play against
your pet opening or do you just sort of
say hey it's another opening i got to do
what i got to do
no actually the opposite i'd love to
play against karo khan i was very much
looking forward to it
um but i don't know like i know the
positions are good and it's like a
consistent
like small advantage but um no i mean
roberto made it very he made it very
difficult like uh even the positions
where i thought looked good
within a few moves he's playing fast and
like i'm
hesitating and all of a sudden i'm down
a minute so
uh he showed his wisdom he's a few years
you know
my senior he had that that that that
wisdom
and like the ability to kind of keep his
nerves down
uh i think better than me and he just
ended up outplaying me and
good position or not you know you have
to win the whole game and uh
he was able to go from start to finish
much more consistently
um some compliments to uh to your
opponent levy i also wanted to ask you
about
um what i felt was kind of a pivotal
moment
in the bullet portion which really sort
of sealed the match um
i'm referring to the bullet game which
pretty much lasted about six minutes
if you remember which one i'm talking
about so uh just wondering what your
thoughts were on that game because
it looked like in terms of the the
gamesmanship that was just really smart
strategy he burned a lot of clock there
yeah i was trying to like get aggressive
in that game and
um and attack but it's just such a blur
like you know you i played london i'm
like i'm gonna go check mate his king
and then
all of a sudden like we have no queens
on the board and i'm like why did i do
that
what's the game the the game you had a
three game lead
in the bullet and i had like 14 maybe
like 12 minutes 11 minutes
i'm like okay if i win now i have a
chance and then the game lasted like
six minutes i was like okay yeah and
then i yeah yeah yeah
almost lost the rook end game yes
yeah yeah no i would do it too don't
worry
yeah i played with the
some time but i i know this
this isn't the best way to to
put the match the chewing but
it's okay uh and i i need i think i need
to
to fix this karaoke with h4
a lot of bad positions with without the
space
i need i need to study this deeply
yeah and well roberto i have a question
for you i mean you've won this event it
was
very hard fought and a job well done
what's next for you i know you stream
you talked about how
you want to become a grandmaster when
more tournaments take place
what's your near future looking like
i just study chess to to improve
my knowledge and waiting for the
presidential tournaments because in
the pandemic is really crazy
and i don't know how much time he
need to to play the the next
uh presidential tournament but uh
are we studying doing my
streaming and learning some chess
probably that sounds like uh
a nice way to go i'll i'll throw the
same sort of question to you levy i mean
we
you mentioned a few different types of
stress that you've had during this
tournament you still made it to the
finals
had an incredible performance and you've
obviously had lots of fans cheering you
on throughout
the event so any any final thoughts here
as the event wraps up
i remember lauren's trent beat danny
wrench and then declared on twitter he
wants to become a grandmaster
it's not as dramatic for me uh at the
end of the day it's all
you know it's uh online blitz and bullet
but it's uh it's fun i think i've had
like my best month of chess in like five
years maybe so
um like i hit my blitz peak i'm very far
from that now but
uh i hit it actually in the second game
against greg it was 28 30. so i'm just
gonna
keep doing keep doing what i do and um
definitely want to wish my opponent best
of luck in getting the the grand master
title because
i've had a lot of people tell me he's
definitely deserving so
best of luck to your regard on that
chair
he deserved wow yeah no i guess that's
the uh
note to end this interview on we
definitely appreciate you both joining
us congrats again roberto and congrats
you too levi you played
marvelously throughout the event and you
were very close to taking this down so
congrats both you and thanks so much
thanks for the commentary guys
it's been amazing thanks for the invite
to a tournament and
it's okay well thank you both and there
we have it
everybody you see the trophy roberto
molina's name
underneath it he has successfully
invaded the cornfield
ahmad he has done it he is the champion
of the i'm not gm speed chess
championship
all of his fans have been spamming the
emote they know what's up
we know what's up and roberto at long
last he's breathing
he's smiling and he can have some relief
he can
well well deserved uh really impressive
tournament
start to finish from uh both players but
obviously you know a special highlight
to the performance of roberto molina in
the finals here i feel like uh you know
the
he was the deserving winner today the
chess reflected that he was tactically
sharp
in the bullet portion and he showed uh
you know that queen trading solid style
that's uh enough to win at defense wins
championships robert
and it's kind of funny because when the
time was actually
less he started being more tactical
rather than less
so something about it was going his way
he found
his footing he was able to win some of
those final three minute games
and in the bullet he showed that he is
2800 plus for a reason and of course
levy put up a great fight
if that final three-minute game had gone
his way maybe this would have been a
different match but i do think
that roberto is the deserving champion
of this tournament and it has been a fun
time with you my partner
oh it certainly has it's been a
tournament that's taken place
over uh months we actually had a break
in the middle of it while the exciting
pog champs event
took place and you know people just
coming back remembering this tournament
still supporting it and and always
coming in and watching with you know
huge huge viewership so
we appreciate the the full uh audience
the full auditorium here as
you know we watched some epic blunders
some
intense matches and uh we even got to
see
um a playoff take place a tiebreaker
in one of the matches so start to finish
robert there's been a lot of
clippable highlight moments for me and
it's just been
awesome to be in the commentary booth
certainly has and
remiss not to thank everybody including
our producers including everyone behind
the scenes making these matches possible
people working on fair play to ensure
that the event is held in the highest
order
and of course everyone in chat the
moderators who are doing a great job not
that they're needed too much because
everyone is so great
so thank you everybody for tuning in for
making this another
special edition of the i'm not jim's
pizza championship and aman
i can't go out here without thanking you
again because it's been so much more fun
commentating alongside you
you made it the best tournament possible
so thank you my friend let's go thank
you very much robert
i i'll hit you right back with some some
praise robert
it's it's been a pleasure one of the
best duos out there i'm gonna say it
while we're still on air
uh thanks for watching guys and what can
we say
keep up with uh with the chat there'll
be lots more events
on chess.com but for now the i am not a
gm uh
tournament brought to you by chess.com
has come to an end
we're gonna be uh taking off take care
guys and we'll see you next time
you